Hello everybody!
Oh it's so weird being on the left side of the screen every time.
I see myself on the left side and I'm like, this is wrong.
This doesn't feel right.
It was like a little dokey jumpscare.
I was like, whoa!
I'm on the left side!
Oh my god!
What the fuck is this?
What the fuck is that?
You know like that YouTube video, that old YouTube video where he's like, Mom!
What the fuck is that cat?
That's how I feel about myself right now.
It's like, Mom!
Look at that cat!
Oh my god!
What the fuck is this?
A little dokey jumpscare because she's on the left side.
There's a weird fucking bird, Mom!
Anyway, hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Today, we're gonna be finishing Shadow of the Clown.
I can't believe it.
After so many five-star reviews, she's gonna close down her massage parlor.
But why dokey?
I thought you were having such good business!
I was having too much of a good thing, you know?
Like, the business was going so well that I can basically retire early.
I'm retiring like 30 years early.
That was just how good.
The tips were just that good.
You know?
It's like they gave away the tips.
They gave away all their life savings to me after the massage parlor was over.
Like, it was crazy.
It's like they didn't need their life savings anymore.
So, um... No, I didn't run out of clients!
No, no, no, no.
I was just doing such a good job that I'm retiring early.
Uh, because, you know, people were just giving me so much money after I finished my appointments!
It's crazy!
It's like their entire life savings!
I just deleted so much stress out of them.
Um, I think I've been like pretty, uh...
You know how I was like, oh yeah, I tried to finish games in three years.
I've been like... I'm like so surprised at myself for being able to like keep that consistent!
The consistency of like finishing a game after like three to four streams.
And it's been like super consistent with me.
So, let's hope that I keep the pace with completing this game today.
I'm gonna not end stream until I kill... I mean, uh, fix.
Until I fix everybody's problems.
Not kill!
I don't know where you heard that.
Alright, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Can you give us a summary of the story so far?
Like, last time in Shadow of Colossus...
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Last time in Shadow of Colossus, I cured...
I cured a bunch of colossi and they were happy.
The end.
Also, I like, neutered one of them, I think.
I solved the iguana issue.
The...
The invasive species of iguanas.
I solved that too.
I just... I'm just a jack of all trades.
Um...
Little life update.
Oh my gosh.
I think, like, next week...
Uh...
I think next week, I'm definitely going to...
Take a bigger break next week.
I'm gonna take, like, a double...
Cause, you know, usually I take Sunday off.
Um...
I think, like, next week I'm gonna take Sunday and Monday off for next week.
Just to, like...
Uh...
Cause, like, one will be...
Cause I know it's, like, rest day.
But I haven't, like, rested in any of my rest days yet.
So...
I'm gonna take back-to-back rest days.
So, one of them will be the rest day, rest day.
And then the other one will be the rest work day.
So, I'm gonna do, like...
So, next week I'm gonna take two back-to-back rest days.
So, like, next week's gonna be, like...
I think, like, three rest days.
Um...
And hope that one of them will actually be resting.
Also, thank you for the super chat, Ninja.
Thank you, thank you.
It's my niece's first birthday.
I thought it would be best to open the credit card in their name.
And send you a super chat with that card.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Ninja.
You know what would be even funnier?
I mean, like, even better idea?
If, like, you just didn't give her that credit card.
You just, you know...
Okay.
This is, like, an ethical life hack.
But, like, you know, like...
After the kid is born...
You know, open a credit card in their name.
And then, you know...
Like...
You know, give them good credit, you know?
They might have a little bit of debt.
And then, when they hit...
When they hit at an age where they have their own money...
Um...
You can give them the card.
And be like, don't worry.
I used it to help you build up credit.
Now, all you have to do is pay off the debt.
Pay off...
Now, all you have to do is pay off the credit card debt.
And then, you'll have great credit.
What?
Start them off young.
Not ruin their credit score.
It's their fault they don't pay it off.
Like, that's credit fraud.
Look, I did say non-ethical life hack.
Okay?
I made sure to say it's not that ethical.
It's just a little bit not that ethical.
And like, for legal reasons, let me just say this is a joke in case the IRS is watching.
Okay, the IRS is American.
What the fuck are you gonna do to me?
I'm in Canada.
Okay, anyway...
I might not be able to visit America anymore after I said that.
And...
To all you Americans out there.
Canadians, don't do this because I can be like child in Canadian court.
But to all you American...
To all you Americans out there.
The CRA will come for you.
Anyway...
What was I saying?
Oh yeah.
Oh my gosh.
It's been like a super duper...
Okay, now fucking Arlo is the main character again.
Ninja, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is fraud only if you get caught.
Anyway...
Life updates.
We have new sub badges!
To be fair, we've had new sub badges for like a couple of days now.
But really haven't had the time to really announce it.
Because we haven't really had like...
I was like...
I think I was like super tired.
So I didn't really...
I forgot to talk about it.
But yes!
We have new sub badges!
Let me see if I can...
I'll pull it up after the stream.
I'm not the stream.
I'll pull it up after we beat the game.
Like the actual...
Like the artwork for it.
But yes!
Yes!
Some of you guys might have already skipped the tomato and the egg form.
So now you're actually dragoons now.
But like...
We have new sub badges!
Oh my god.
Look at all these dragoons!
Any fresh tomatoes out there that we can eat?
Any rare tomatoes?
So...
Speaking of rare tomatoes...
We have a new Doki Bites short from Llama.
And like...
They really...
I don't know if you guys noticed but it's actually like a spiritual continuation of the other short that Llama make.
Where like...
It was like a magical girl transformation.
And then the backwards for like the rare tomato.
So...
The rare tomato transformation.
I just need you guys to know that I made Llama tone it down.
A lot more than what the original was.
The original was like...
The original was a little bit more graphic.
Just saying.
I was like...
Oh yeah.
No.
We gotta...
Oh yeah.
We gotta change that up.
Like...
You know...
Even though this isn't really a Christian stream.
Like you know...
This isn't really for kids.
But like...
We don't wanna be R-rated.
You know?
Lord Crow says thank you for the 10 gift dishes.
Thank you.
Also Trashboy.
Welcome back to the tomato farm.
Welcome.
But yes.
Anyway.
So...
It was originally the...
The...
The quote on quote tomato juice.
Was more tomato...
Tomato...
Flavor.
Sorry.
Was more tomato colored.
I was like...
Oh yeah.
No.
Let's just Danganronpa this.
I was like...
Oh yeah.
We're gonna have to Danganronpa this a bit.
So people...
You know.
So YouTube won't be like...
Is that blood?
Cause I've got hit by...
It's very surprising.
Because I actually didn't get hit by Limited for the short.
Because I said to change it to Danganronpa color.
For those who don't know the reference.
It's like the hyper pink.
So it doesn't...
It doesn't look like actual like ketchup.
You know?
So it doesn't...
And then...
Um...
Release the Llamaca.
Thank you for the super chat.
Darkblade.
Thank you.
So I was like...
Yeah.
Let's just...
Let's make the tomato juices like...
You know.
More neon pink.
Instead of...
You know.
Tomato ketchup color.
Because...
I don't...
Yeah.
I don't wanna fucking...
I don't wanna get in trouble here.
And also like...
The sounds was a lot worse.
There was...
Okay.
So there was one where...
I don't know if you watched the short.
There was one where the leaves were coming out of the head.
And then there was the...
It was...
The sound for that was...
Not great.
Like it was very like...
Yeah.
And I was like...
Bro.
Okay.
We're gonna remove the sound for the head part.
Because like...
I think like...
You know.
All the others...
You can see the...
The stick limbs.
But then on the head...
When you hear that sound...
It's pretty bad.
I don't know.
Especially when...
It's at the head.
So we gonna...
I'm gonna have to ask to remove that...
Because...
Because I'm worried.
So we had to...
We had to like...
Tone it down a little bit.
Because I didn't want to...
I just want you guys to know...
The reason why I asked to tone it down...
The experience I've had, not on this channel, but there was a short on another channel that got hit by limited ads and was marked by YouTube because there was blood on it.
And they were like, no, no, no, that's blood.
So I was like, okay, now I know.
It's funny that the sound didn't get hit by the limited ads, but I think it's because they're like, oh, hey, look, it's not red.
So it's not actually blood.
So you're okay, Doki.
You're okay, Doki.
I was like, oh my gosh, I was so surprised.
Anyway, artistic integrity is shabby.
Thank you, MagentaSoupa.
Thank you, thank you.
So I got from that experience, I figured out like how to bypass the censorship on YouTube because apparently ad companies...
Like the current version.
Also another funny thing regarding updates.
So I was like talking to my YouTube guy being like, so why is like some of my VODs getting hit by limited recently?
Because I've never had that experience before.
And then my YouTube guy was like looking through the VODs because like I have to like, I get hit by limited.
And then after the stream, I get hit by limited.
And then I have to like appeal it.
I have to like actually appeal it and be like, why is this hit by limited?
Like what the fuck's going on?
And then my YouTube guy looked at it.
Like the content warning.
I got hit by limited ads on the content warning stream.
So I got really confused.
I was like, why the fuck did I get hit by limited ads?
And then I appealed it and then they got like fixed the date like a couple hours later.
And then my YouTube guy was like, oh, yeah, I'm looking through the VODs and I think it's because of profi-
Yeah, like you swear a lot.
I was like, what the fuck?
What do you mean?
Profanity!
And he was like, well, you do swear a lot in the beginning of these videos.
And I think like the auto detection was like, that's a lot of swearing.
He's like, I guess it's profanity.
I can't see why else you got hit.
And then...
And then I was like, that is bullshit!
Okay, I didn't say that.
I was like, okay, this is what I say.
I was like, that's so weird.
Because in the past, I rarely, if ever, got hit by profanity.
So I was like, what do you mean profanity?
I've never changed the way I talk.
I've always had profanity.
Why now?
Why?
I was like, why?
Why did I get hit by profanity now of all times?
So...
Um...
So yeah, so that's why I've been being hit by limited.
But the thing is, I just have to appeal it.
And then they're like, okay, you're good now.
But it was so weird.
It hits me like ever so often.
Like one or two streams.
It'll be like one stream and then the next stream will be okay.
Or maybe two streams in a row will get hit by limited.
And the next stream will be okay.
And I just have to appeal it.
Every time I appeal it, they're like, good to go.
But I was so surprised.
I was like, profanity?
Another update.
Another life update.
Um...
I've been so fucking busy.
Because like every day I have like...
Oh my gosh.
I have like these like business meetings.
Or like business decisions to make and stuff like that.
Oh my gosh.
I don't want to like spoil anything.
But...
It's been a problem.
Where I have so many...
It's so difficult.
I hate making decisions.
I hate making choices.
Especially when I do want to do everything.
Goodbye Arlo.
He's going to be the main character again.
Because like there's like instances where...
So like one of these things I can talk about is that you know like the Doki Bird World Tour?
It's come to a point where we have...
There's like so many conventions are asking for me to be a guest.
That like the dates are conflicting with each other.
So I have to pick and choose.
Which convention I want to do.
And I was like...
I hate it because I want to do them all.
I want to do them all.
So then I was like...
Oh my gosh.
Like there's like so many conventions.
And I was like...
Oh man I want to do this.
And I also want to do that.
But I have to pick one.
Because there's only one Doki Bird for those days.
And I was like...
No.
There's so many.
So like there's going to be a point where there's going to be a convention.
For me.
Like almost every month.
We haven't hit that streak.
We have obviously like...
There's no conventions in April.
No conventions in April.
Because I was a little too late.
But like...
We're going to have a convention.
Almost like a convention guest.
Almost every month.
And it's going to be like around the world type deal.
So it's like...
Oh it won't be like just focusing on one area.
Just NA or anything.
Just think it's the world tour for a reason.
It's the world tour for a reason.
So just get ready.
We're just going to be a lot of Doki Birds.
So...
Oh my gosh.
But it makes me so sad.
Because I can only pick like one.
Like I can only do like one.
Not like...
Like you know when there's so many going at the same time.
Like on the same dates too.
I think that's the worst part.
When they're on the same date.
And I can only do one.
And I'm like...
No.
But what if I want to do them all.
On.
Is that fair?
I just want to do them all.
But yeah that's basically what it's been like at the moment.
What's going on right now.
Pastries.
I know.
But like they're all so fun to do.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Alright thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Idea.
Hire a Doki Bird too.
She can make appearances in Spongebob ships for you.
Easy.
If only it was that easy.
Anyway.
Alright.
Let's actually play.
Let me move my...
Let me move myself real fast.
Let's look at...
Let's look at a different screen.
Alright.
Time to look at the...
At the gaming screen.
Alright.
That was the life updates.
Now we actually game.
Woo!
Alright.
Massage parlor is open.
Continue.
The massage parlor is now open.
Alright.
Where am I?
Hello.
That's me.
Don't worry.
The specialist is here.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where do I go?
Where the fuck do I go?
Time to actually game.
Sorry.
It took me 20 minutes to get started.
But here we go.
Where the fuck...
Where do I go?
Why is my sword not taking me anywhere?
Oh.
This way.
Alright.
Arlo.
Let's go.
Come on.
Arlo.
You had like...
You had 20 minutes to rest.
Arlo.
Why are you just walking?
You had 20 minutes to rest.
The rest...
Arlo.
Alright.
The tangent was necessary to the plot.
Here we go.
I can't believe it.
Okay.
I can't believe it either.
I can't believe I forgot how to ride a horse.
Alright.
Let's see.
How do I do this?
Nope.
That's duck.
That's my sword.
How do I...
Guys.
Oh.
Okay.
It's...
It's triangle.
I figured it out, guys.
I figured it out.
Okay.
So...
I'm gonna go to the other side.
The next coloss...
My next appointment is like this way.
Here we go.
This is my next appointment.
I have so many projects going on behind the scenes, but...
It's actually...
You're like, how many...
Are you...
How much stuff are you doing behind the scenes?
And I'm like, yes.
Every day, I wake up to like 20 plus discreet messages.
I was like, I wake up and I was like, oh, god.
I just got mad.
I will get...
I took a deep, deep shower and I'm like, dude.
I don't want to know, like, what my habit is and I'm like, okay, that got me a little bit of a headache.
Oh, my god.
Oh, my God.
I'm really like...
Oh my God.
Oh, my God.
It seems that's gonna build up soon so we can actually have something fun on the channel.
How do I... is it like this way?
I guess it's on the... it has to be on the other side.
We're still cooking.
We're cooking so many things right now.
Back to back.
Cease!
You're gonna burn out!
Guys, the thing is I'm like a huge workaholic.
But like also like I still... I still... I do need like rest days though.
The reason why I have rest days is because I do want to rest at some points.
But like I think like I can like work as well on the rest day.
But like I just want to like not talk.
Like you know be like... be like a mute for a day.
And I think like that's what's like tilting for me.
When I have to like do... like actually use my mouth.
When I have to actually like talk and like do like business meetings and make like business decisions.
On my rest day.
Like but I can't like do it via text.
I'm fine if like it's via text or something.
Like oh make this decision.
And then like... have I been here before?
Have I killed the salamander here before?
Time to pray.
But like if it's like... I don't know.
Actually can't tell.
I can't tell.
All these shrines are blurring together.
Oh no I haven't!
Look there's a salamander right here!
But like... if I have to like use my...
mouth during my rest day.
That's when I get tilted.
That's when I'm like... please.
Please I just wanna be a mute for a day and not talk.
Cause I wanna make sure my throat will be okay.
Where the fuck is that bitch?
I thought we solved the invasive species issue.
Where is him?
Where is he?
Hello?
Where the fuck is he?
Where did he go?
Hello?
Little iguana boy?
Where the fuck is he?
Where did he go?
Alright we're gonna have to climb.
Guys give me a second.
You remember how to climb?
Guys the most important mechanic.
Give me a second.
Okay alright.
It's RT.
Alright.
I need to fucking grab some HP.
Oh my gosh no.
Where did he go?
I don't see him anymore.
He vanished.
Alright.
Give me this way.
Okay.
And then...
This way.
He has to show up somewhere.
How the fuck do I climb this?
How do I climb this?
Oh my god.
Excuse me?
There's nothing I can grab?
Oh there it is.
Alright there you go.
And got it.
Thanks Arlo for just watching me and not helping at all.
Alright.
He has to be here.
Oh there he is.
That's fucking right.
I see you.
Oh you bitch!
You fucker.
Okay.
He dropped down?
Where did he go?
Where the fuck did he go?
Oh you little fuck.
Okay I see you.
I see you.
Can't hide from me forever.
I'm gonna fucking eat you.
No!
Jesus!
Okay.
I'm gonna eat you soon.
It might not be now.
But I swear to god I'm gonna eat you.
Okay let's... I can figure out how to climb up again.
Ugh.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck do I climb?
Okay here you go.
Okay this one has to be the hardest one.
The other one... The other just like walked into my mouth.
I don't know why.
Why don't you wanna be consumed?
Like... Why not?
It'll be like a fun journey to my stomach.
Alright.
Here we go.
Up.
Yay!
Oh.
Up.
There you go.
Where the fuck is Salamander again?
Where did he go?
Where is he?
Oh I hear him.
No!
Stop!
I hear his feet.
They're like Bomberman feet.
The pa pa pa pa pa pa pa.
Okay.
Where is he?
Okay if I do it like this will he...
Will he like... If I stealth...
Maybe if I stealth like this he'll show up.
No!
No no no no no no no!
Climb back up!
Please!
I need that stamina!
Where did he go?
How did you see me?
Oh.
He didn't see me.
He's just casually back there.
This is so fucked up.
How the fuck do I get to here?
Okay what if I like...
Oh I got an idea.
I got an idea.
I'm just gonna slowly walk to the other side.
I'm gonna slowly walk to the other side and then like...
I'll have the perfect angle on him.
Right here.
Come on.
You gotta get up.
You gotta climb up.
You can't hang in there forever.
There you go.
The perfect angle.
Nice.
Okay.
There you go.
I'm just gonna hit the side.
Watch this.
Okay.
Now watch this.
There he got 12-jew!
Where did he go?
Oh my god.
He has to be dead.
There's no way he's alive.
I should... Oh yeah.
He fucking disappeared.
Thank god.
That has to be the hardest one so far.
So far.
I knew it.
Alright.
Time to kill...
Now time to kill the colossi.
Alright.
Where is it?
Nope.
That's not the sword.
When will I get a magic bow?
I feel like I deserve it.
This way.
Okay.
Alright.
Thank you to that backseater that told me that I don't have to actually navigate my horse.
I don't have to actually move my horse.
He does the auto-travel for me.
Okay.
Where is that?
Where the fuck is that?
Is this?
There's no oasis here.
God.
I wish the maps actually work.
Oh wait.
Have I...
Have I consumed these fruits before?
No I haven't.
Alright.
It's fruit time.
It's time to eat the fruit.
Alright.
Let's see.
Fruit time!
Snack break!
Alright.
Boop.
Can horses just eat grass and then survive?
Or do they actually need real food?
Is it possible if you just like...
Oh hey.
Did they just eat grass?
Can they survive?
Yeah?
Wait.
That's really?
They don't need actual hay?
So like I can just leave a horse in somebody's backyard and they'll be okay?
Can we live off grass?
So like does that mean like humans can live off grass too?
Or are we just like fucked?
Cause like grass is vegetables.
If you think about it.
No?
Why not?
Why can animals live off grass when we can't?
They still need water?
There's water on grass.
Like grass need water to live.
And then like...
If grass need water to live.
It's like cactus.
When you eat a cactus there's water inside.
We can't digest grass?
You need more stomachs to digest grass?
God we're so fucking weak.
Why can't we genetically modify ourselves dude?
This is why we need survival of the fittest.
So you know how like for insects?
You know how like we...
Selective bred them?
And...
Wait that's eugenics.
Wait that's bad.
Disregard everything I said.
Guys that was a joke guys.
Guys that was a joke.
That was...
That was a fucking joke guys.
Pull back.
We don't need six stomachs guys.
No we don't.
We don't need six stomachs.
We're fine.
We don't need six stomachs guys.
One is good enough.
Why would we need to eat grass?
Don't be fucking stupid chat.
Don't be...
Don't be fucking...
Don't be stupid.
One is enough.
Why would we need all these...
Where the fuck is my sun GPS?
Where is my sun GPS?
Oh my god.
We're in a desert and I don't have a GPS.
How do I live?
Oh it's right here.
It's right here.
Don't deny me my third stomach like this.
All I'm saying is that...
Okay you know how like how stick insects are born?
Like how we've like...
How stick insects like evolved?
Basically like it's not that they know what sticks look like.
It's that eventually the insect like you know the insects that don't look like a stick got eaten up too many times by the birds.
And then like at one point that the insects that looked like sticks were able to live on and like breathe like crazy and then become the sick insects that it's become.
So like we should...
Ethically speaking it's so fucked up.
But like...
Don't double down.
What if like...
Okay what if...
Okay what if like...
Alright.
This is gonna be a little bit of like...
Like...
Like philosophical thing.
Like it's gonna be based off that movie with like Andrew Garfield where like the clone...
We start cloning.
Like at one point we're gonna be able to start cloning.
And then we clone like these people.
We start cloning ourselves but they have like no...
Because they're clones.
You know they have...
They have you know...
Yeah they're not real...
They're not real people if you think about it.
Okay so like...
So like we put these clones...
We put these clones in a room and it's just grass.
And the room will just be...
Be grass, you know.
And then...
And then so like the thing is...
The thing is...
Eventually the clone with the three...
Eventually the clones will evolve until...
Until...
I'm not ignoring it.
I'm trying to figure out the GPS right now.
The clones will evolve in a way where they eventually have more than one stomach because...
Because we just put them in a room filled with grass.
And then at one point...
At one point, the clones will be able to have...
They will be able to evolve into people with more than one stomach.
And then we take those clones and they are now...
They... and then like, you know...
We put them with the real humans.
And then they will make babies...
With the clone DNA with more than one stomach.
There you go.
Where the fuck is the entrance?
Is it here?
Is... have I been like dodging this hole this entire...
No, that's not a...
That does not look like a safe hole.
That is... unless...
Unless... it has to be here.
Where else would it be?
I've been like fucking walking around to this...
Same hole... multiple times.
It has to be this hole.
Where else could it be?
Okay, this seems safe, right?
Is it safe?
What if...
I'm just trying to make the optimal human where we can survive off grass alone.
It'll solve like food shortages.
We can literally just go outside and eat the grass.
If we have more than one stomach.
Like think about it guys.
I don't know.
If we have more than one stomach.
Then we can just eat grass.
And then it'll be like optimal survival.
The optimal human.
Because like at that point we'll have like enough.
We'll be able to like consume...
Oh my god, it's all the way over there.
Okay, but what if I just jump?
Can't be that bad.
I mean I already prayed.
Okay guys.
Alright.
Guys, I'm stuck.
Oh my god.
Oh my...
No!
Guys.
I lived.
I lived!
I fucking knew it!
I knew it.
I knew it would work.
I knew it would work guys.
I'm a fucking genius.
Arlo get down from here.
I lived.
Guys, this is it.
Guys, I am the optimal human being.
If we like...
If we clone me.
And then...
Guys.
Guys, we can have like Doki clones that can survive bigger falls guys.
Think about it.
I can't see this.
What the fuck is...
What...
Where am I going?
Oh, is it here?
This has to be it.
Total Doki-fication.
Guys, just think about how many like conventions I can go to.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What the fuck do I do here?
Whoa!
Ow!
Okay.
Where am I?
Where...
Where did he fucking knock me?
All right, guys.
We got the...
Where am I?
Oh, it's this way.
How the fuck did he knock me off?
What the fuck?
Okay, here we go.
Here we go again.
All right.
I can barely see the stage.
What the fuck do I do?
Arrel?
Okay, Arrel.
Okay.
Boop!
You don't do like that.
You can't get me because you can't walk up ramps.
Hehe.
Where the fuck do I go?
What a loser.
Yeah, you wish you can get me right now.
Bet you.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
I'm here for the session, guys.
Bro, how am I supposed to give you acupuncture if I can't even see where the acupuncture?
Alright, where is his fucking heart?
Oh yeah, there's no sun.
Alright,
we haven't...
Wait, where am I?
I jumped down again.
Sorry, guys.
Okay.
Okay, this time.
This time.
It's so hard to see, bro!
Turn off your fucking brightness!
How?
I don't know!
Turn off your fucking brightness!
I can barely see where it starts!
Okay, I'm here.
I'm here now.
Oh my god, I need to climb up.
Can I climb up this?
Bro, like, go near the fire.
Alright, I'm near the fire.
Here I am.
I have the light now.
I have the high ground.
What are you gonna do about it?
Oh.
That's right!
Nothing!
Can't do anything about it!
I live here now!
Wait, what's this?
Oh, shit.
Guys, I was just joking, sir.
Sir, sir, sir.
I was just joking.
Please let me get up, sir.
Sir, please.
Please do.
Sir, please!
Please do not sunlock me, sir!
This is not a fighting game!
Sir, please!
We're... we...
Where am I?
Where even am I?
Oh there it is!
I see it!
Ow!
Please, sir, let me grab the torch!
No!
I can barely see the fucking screen!
Alright, let's- here we go again.
Guys, guys, I swear to god.
This is like the most diff- it's so dark!
Oh my god, I can barely- okay, here we go.
I'm gonna fall, alright?
I feel like I'm gonna fall again.
Bro, why are you edgeguarding?
Are you fucking playing Smash Bros or some shit?
Oh god, oh god.
Be gone.
Ow!
Guys, I don't think he likes me.
Is this even on fire?
No, it's not.
No, please!
Let me climb!
Please.
At least let me get up, please!
Oh god.
This is so fucked up, man.
This is actually so fucked up.
Oh god, I'm okay.
Guys, it's okay!
Guys!
It's okay!
I'm okay, guys.
Don't worry.
Oh, thank god.
Oh, thank god he stopped.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
And god said, let there be light.
Ow!
Okay.
Alright.
Be gone!
Go to the light!
No!
Fuck!
Go to the light!
I need light to work!
Sir!
There you go.
We're fine.
Oh, thank god.
Alright.
That's all we have to do.
We took off his clothes.
He'll be fine.
Where is he?
Where the fuck did he land?
Where did his body go?
What the fuck?
Bro, he's gone.
Where is his body?
Did he land all the way here?
Oh, he did.
What the fuck?
Why is he here?
Okay.
Knife time.
Stabby stab!
Wee!
Alright.
Here we go.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Thank fucking god, bro.
Okay.
Look at all the stress juice in your back, sir!
Those not healthy men!
Keeping all that inside you!
Oh god.
Oh.
Sir!
We got a cracker!
I'm a chiropractor too now as well.
I just got my chiropractor license.
Yeah!
Guys, I'm a licensed chiropractor.
Oh my god.
Did you guys ever see the YouTube video of chiropractors for dogs?
And I'm just like how...
That's like the scariest shit ever.
Doing chiro...
Fucking...
Fucking doing that to dogs?
Please...
Guys, I'm like that...
I'm like that guy in Gumball where he has...
When he's like everywhere because he has so many jobs and licenses.
That's me.
I gotta make money somehow.
Okay.
Please.
Please just let me poke you in the back!
Oh god.
Oh my god.
I don't know why he doesn't like it.
It's like a little scratch.
Okay.
Alright, one... two more stabs maybe.
Please, please, please.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, what if I just stand here like this?
Okay.
Sorry, I recharged it a little.
It's okay.
I'll just stand here like this.
What?
No!
I have to do it again!
Oh god.
Oh, please get up.
Why is your recovery rate so bad?
Truly the chastisement of the YouTuber.
Thank you for the super chat cast.
Thank you.
How is your recovery rate this bad?
Alright.
Can you jump here?
I'm gonna do it again.
Where did I leave my fucking stick though?
Oh no.
I don't know where I left my stick.
Alright.
Can you jump over here?
Can you get here?
Where is he?
Where did he go?
Sir?
Did I fall down again?
I fucking...
God damn it.
Ha!
Where did he go?
Oh!
He's behind me, isn't he?
Oh shit!
Okay.
Guys, he was behind me.
How do I get up?
He got bored.
But how do I...
Oh god, please don't slap me.
Please don't slap me.
Oh!
It's okay.
We're gonna figure this out.
Get up.
Oh, my god.
Oh!
It's okay.
You can't kill me.
What doesn't kill me?
Make me stronger!
Oh!
No!
It's okay.
I'm okay, guys.
I'm okay.
How do I get back up?
Jesus Christ.
Do you know where the exit is?
Oh, my...
Please!
Sir, can you get downstairs?
Oh, no.
I'm sorry.
Oh, my god.
There must be a way.
Oh!
Fuck!
Okay.
I did not mean to.
I don't know, guys.
I don't know how to get back up.
I don't know how to get back onto his back, guys.
Maybe he'll...
Oh, I have an idea.
Watch this.
He's gonna be so confused.
There's no way.
He's gonna go right here and then I can be like...
Oh!
What the...
Insert the shield.
Oh!
Of course, it works.
I planned it all along.
Guys, of course that works.
I always knew it was gonna work.
I'm a licensed professional.
Oh, my...
Please!
Why is this so...
Why is he so difficult?
All right.
Nice turn.
Again.
Okay.
We're almost there.
We just need two more pokes.
Sir, calm down.
Calm down!
It doesn't hurt too bad!
That's not play!
You just have so much stress on your back!
Please!
We just need to hear a good crack!
There we go.
He don't wanna die.
He's not gonna die!
I'm a licensed professional!
Die, guys!
He's not a licensed professional!
We're back!
Another client satisfied!
Yeah, have you guys seen the chiropractor for dogs?
It's actually crazy.
You can hear it crack while he tries to break the dog's back.
Well, he's not breaking the dog's back, but it's so disturbing.
Cause it's like, how do you know if they like it?
Like how do you know they actually like that?
They can't verbally tell you, be like, ow, that is not helping.
That's the neat part, they don't.
Just ask the dog.
Hey little doggy, was that a happy yelp or a not happy yelp?
You guys never seen it?
Okay, wait, I'm gonna find that YouTube video.
Paradise floats upon the lake, aside- no, it's gonna be water again.
No,
not the water, colossus.
I think that's the worst one.
The water ones are the worst.
The water ones and the ones that had to do with the horse.
Because I'm not very good at driving horses.
Gary, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Man, Doki got beat up for real, for real.
I know, I was just trying to help.
I can't believe it, they don't trust professionals.
Okay, chiropractor for animal- for dogs.
I saw it on Twitter and I was like...
Oh my god, bro, some of them- he does it to tiny dogs too.
And I'm like, what the fuck?
And you can see the dogs are like, what the fuck?
Oh my god, the one with the corky.
The cork is like, Jesus Christ.
I'm trying to find the one with like...
Um...
The one where he was like...
He like hugged the dog and he was like...
I'm like...
I think it was this one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it was this one.
Check this video out.
The corky was like, no.
Oh my god.
The one where he like fucking- it's like a wrestling move.
Where he like picks up the dog underneath the armpits.
And he's like...
I'm like, what the fuck?
I don't know, they're like, it improves the standard of living.
I'm like, but you don't even know what- if they're- they can't talk.
I'm just like, how do you- how do you know?
Snap, crackle, and pop.
Am I right, chat?
Plastic, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, let me...
Let me...
Pray real fast.
They looked relaxed.
I just wondered like, how do you trial and error it correctly?
To become a professional too.
Cause it's like, dog skeletons are not the same as human skeletons.
So I'm just like, how- they all just all look very- yeah cause they're like, what the fuck?
That dog is like- they're like, what the fuck is this person doing?
And then like, suddenly their bones feel different?
Like...
Oh my god.
That sounds like- that's so fucking freaky.
It's like, oh my god.
Like, how we invent stuff, you don't think like, how long it took for us to invent.
Okay, this is fucked up for me to say.
But it's like, when did we figure out how to- Neutering sucks!
It's like, it's similar!
It's similar, the trial and error.
When did we figure out what- how- how- how neutering works?
It's- oh, then stop smiling after.
How long did it take?
Same with poison!
The fact that we know what's poisonous and what's not.
Like, you have to remember how many times it take us to like, figure out which mushrooms we can eat and which we can't.
Cause like, there's like mushrooms that look the same to each other and then...
And then we have to like, figure out what mushroom was like, poisonous and which one wasn't.
There's some hilarious- yeah, they're like, what the fuck?
As soon as they crack the body, they're like, the fuck?
Alright, we go...
Is this the water?
Is the water there?
Wait, is it underneath here?
It's like how like, back in the medieval times, there would be poison testers.
We know- yeah, exactly.
Experience, not our experience.
Oh no, not the wad.
We gotta find- how many lakes are here?
Alright, we gotta find another lake.
We gotta find another lake, chat.
It's a never ending cycle of lakes.
We're never- oh my god, please.
Arlo, please.
Find me a lake.
Alright, here you go.
Salute to all those dogs we've tested to perfect.
Salute to the falls.
There you go.
This way.
This has to be where the lake is.
Is this the lake?
This has to be.
There's water here.
Okay, how do I get down here?
Okay, can I die from this lake?
There's no way.
There's no way I'll die from this lake, right?
Right?
No, that seems like a pretty deep lake.
Nevermind.
I mean that's...
Okay.
Is it this lake?
Is it this one?
Is this the lake?
Not this one?
God.
God, there's way too many lakes.
Oh, is it this one?
It has to be this lake.
I don't like it down though.
Is it this lake?
It's pointing there.
How many other lakes are there?
This has to be the only lake.
The bridge?
Oh, okay.
You're right.
There is a bridge there.
Jump.
Do it, Doki.
You'll be so funny.
Alright, we're gonna go to that bridge.
It has to be the bridge over there.
I've never like...
I don't know.
Has anyone ever went to a chiropractor before?
It's always so scary whenever I see videos of people doing chiropractor.
Like, what is it called?
Chiro... chiro...
What is the verb?
Whenever someone went to get chiropracted, it wants to work for it.
Chiropractor?
Chiropracted?
Like, it's always so scary because...
Because it's like they pull...
Like, there's ones where they pull your neck up and stuff.
And then you hear a fucking crack.
I'm like, Jesus Christ.
Like, it just looks painful in a way to...
That like scares the shit out of me.
They just call it chiropractice?
I don't know.
Like, the fact that your entire body is like...
You know...
What if they...
Sorry, I might be giving people internal fears right now.
And like never go to chiropractice or anything because of what I'm saying.
But like...
But what if like...
It's just weird because they're like putting their entire body...
And you just hear like crack sound and shit like that.
That's so fucking scary to me.
You are.
Just like me in planes.
Please, why don't you...
Arlo, why aren't you going?
Oh my God, I'm just gonna walk over.
God damn it, Arlo.
He doesn't like the fucking water stream.
And I don't know why.
I don't know why.
I don't know why he's here.
Can I jump down?
Guys, we cannot jump down.
Do not.
Do not jump down.
But where do I go?
Where the fuck do I go?
Where the fuck is that bridge?
It's not here.
Maybe the other side?
Do a flip.
Guys, I'm not gonna try.
Guys, I don't wanna walk back down.
Doki, don't worry.
You can make that jump.
You totally can.
Guys, I don't know.
Whenever you guys say do it, for some reason, I feel like I can't.
Trial and error, Doki.
Remember what you said.
This is not the same thing and you know it.
This is not the same.
It has to be here.
You can?
Not with that attitude?
Don't do it.
Guys, I'm getting like different...
I'm getting like conflicting answers here.
Is it not here?
Where is my light telling me to go?
There's literally a sun.
Where is my...
It's like here.
It's in there?
How the fuck do I get in there?
There's no way.
I cannot even see the end.
The waterfall just stops watering.
Like...
It doesn't even head downstairs.
It just stops.
Like what?
Why did it stop?
There has to be like a cave, right?
Where the lake came from?
Right?
There has to be.
Well, nope.
That's where the lake is.
Oh my god.
I'm so lost, Arlo.
I'm so...
It doesn't...
It doesn't even head downstairs.
Okay.
How much money would you guys bet on it?
If you bet money on it...
Are you right?
Wait, wait.
There's a hole here.
Guys.
Guys, there's an extra hole.
Wait, maybe it's here.
There's an extra hole here that I didn't go through.
Look how Arlo is just trailing behind me.
Wait, have I been here?
That's a shrine, right?
I think I've been here before.
There's a shrine right here.
Have I been here before?
This has to be it, right?
Oh no, this is where I came from.
Guys, sorry.
This is...
Sorry, my GPS malfunctioned there.
This is exactly where I've been.
Deja vu, guys.
Deja vu.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck do I go?
Like, it's just empty.
It's just nowhere.
Is there a bridge there?
There has to be like a bridge somewhere.
It can't just be like nothing.
Why would there be a cliff here?
Why the fuck?
Okay, I'm gonna do it.
I don't know.
For some reason, the main character is so scared.
And I don't know why.
Guys, why does he seem so scared about jumping down, guys?
Why does...
Unless it's not the right way.
Better.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I did.
I followed the water.
There was like multiple waters.
Follow...
I did.
This is it.
They won't let me go forward.
Okay, I'll find...
I'll follow this trail of water.
Where does this trail of water lead me?
Oh, nowhere?
Oh, nothing?
Look at that.
Nothing!
It just leads me to this.
Which is nothing.
Check the map.
I am checking the map.
What am I looking at?
Try the other water.
There was nothing here!
It's nothing!
Okay, climb it.
Climb what?
The fucking air?
Guys.
Wait, what the fuck is this?
Oh, okay, I got like a token.
Guys, I got an easter egg.
Was that it?
That opening over there!
It's right there, Doki!
God, open your eyes!
Alright, we're gonna go check the other fucking opening then.
Guys, the next opening is the fucking waterfall!
That's another waterfall!
What do you mean there?
It's literally water!
It's right there, Doki!
It's right there!
Oh my god, circle emoji!
Right there!
You just ran past it again, Doki!
Oh my god, stop running past it!
Follow the water, not on the water.
Oh my god, how many waters do I follow?
Fine, I'm gonna follow the water again!
I'm following the water!
I'm following it!
Woah!
Where is this water gonna take me?
Oh my god!
Water?
Right here?
Woah!
There's like no holes here either.
Am I even in the right hole?
Like, am I supposed to be here?
Like...
This is insane.
Guys, I swear to fucking god, am I actually not missing it?
Am I... Am I... Am I like actually like too blind to see the fucking hole?
Like...
There's no way there's actually a hole here that I'm missing.
I refuse to believe I'm actually missing something.
It's hard to find the hole.
There's a road that follows... Is this not the road?
Is this... There's other holes?
Where do the... Where are the other holes?
Oh my god, go back.
This is what we call the river.
Alright, alright.
Let's see.
Chat GPS.
Let's go.
It's like Chat GPT, but like more confusing apparently.
Alright, here we go.
Wait, is that a hole?
Right here?
No, that's just the water.
That's not the hole.
Alright, we're following the river!
We're following the river!
See the open... That way?
There's an opening?
I think, yeah, we hundred percent need yellow paint.
What opening?
Leave the woods where you came in and follow... There's more to the canyon?!
Was I not even supposed to be in the fucking forest?
Oh my fucking god, oh I'm leaving.
Apparently, I'm not even supposed to be in this forest, guys.
I can't... Guys, that's all you have to say, leave the...
Leave the forest?
Guys, you could have said leave the fucking forest.
Chat, that's all you had to say.
I would have left the forest.
There you go.
There's the hole.
I found the hole, guys.
Guys, I figured it out.
I left the goddamn fucking forest.
And then there's another area.
Guys, who would have thought there was more to life than the fucking forest?
There it is.
Alright.
We did it.
We figured it out, guys.
Guys, I don't know why none of you guys said leave the fucking forest.
Why did all of you make me go with... Why did all of you fucking say follow the river?
A whole new hole.
But we had a good time at the forest.
We could have left the forest, guys.
We didn't have to be in the forest.
Alright, here we go.
Can't believe some of you guys were like, just jump.
I'm not gonna... Guys, I would jump only if the safe spot...
Wait.
He has a white tail.
Oh, it's because this is the shrine!
I was like, wait, where's the shrine for this?
Alright.
Time to burn that forest down.
The less forest there are, the less I'll get lost.
Guys, for legal reasons, that is a joke.
I used to be president of the environmental club.
I would never willingly burn the forest down.
Woop.
There you go.
Where is he?
Is he still alive?
Oh, he is.
Not anymore.
Wait, what?
Oh yeah, he's dead.
Not anymore.
God, good.
More stamina.
Alright, here.
Woop.
There you go.
Woop, I got down.
Sorry.
There we go.
Now!
This has to be the lake.
Oh my god, there's the lake!
How the fuck do I get into the lake?
Oh, I have to climb.
Okay.
Alright.
Don't worry, Arlo.
You can swim too, Arlo, right?
Arlo, just do the jump!
It'll be so funny!
Arlo!
It'll be so funny if you make that jump!
You have more momentum!
We actually made it to the lake.
Oh, thank fucking god.
We made it.
Holy shit.
There's way too many lakes in this area.
There's way too many fucking lakes, guys.
Alright.
Down I go.
Yay!
He has to be here, right?
Alright.
Is it faster if I swim underwater?
It is, right?
Sorry, I can hold my breath for a long time.
The more salamander tails you eat, the longer you can hold your breath.
Real.
I learned this in a video game.
Guys, every time...
Because we all know, video games are so real.
Where is he?
Where is this monster?
Ooh, why is there like three podiums there?
Yeah!
Of course!
I eat those salamander tails.
Trust me, guys.
I'm thinking...
Like...
Can salamander tails be food?
Because like...
It's like an infinite food glitch, you know?
You get a bunch of salamanders and like...
You know, they can regrow their tails, right?
So like all you...
I feel like if I had this conversation...
I feel like I've had this conversation before.
But...
But like think about it.
Like...
Because like the tails are still meat, you know?
So like...
What if you just...
You just...
You just like farm a bunch of salamanders...
And then...
And then all you do is just, you know...
Every time you're hungry, you eat the salamander tail and then...
Wait for it to regrow and then...
But then you have like a farm of them.
And they just...
They don't always grow back.
Then you just kill it!
It's...
We're back to selective breeding!
Like...
We evolve...
Oh shit, that guy's cool.
We evolve the ones that like...
That grow their tails faster!
Okay, we keep them on the farm.
It's like the whole grass thing again.
Oh shit!
Ow!
That hurt!
But he has electricity and water?
Oh my god!
That's fucked up!
Why do you have electricity power?
It's fucked up!
You're just gonna like electrocute yourself!
Oh god, okay.
Okay, he doesn't see me.
He can't.
This is not realistic.
I should have been electrified as well as all the fish around me.
No, all I'm saying is infinite food glitch.
Just think about it.
It's literally an infinite food glitch because they can grow back their tails.
So like if you're hungry, you just eat the tails and they're still alive.
They're still alive, right?
So...
Oh my god.
Please for the love of god!
Where can I climb you?
Stop following me!
Okay.
Oh, this is not fair because he turns faster than me swimming.
Like how the fuck am I supposed to figure this out?
Yeah, we feed them bugs!
Bugs reproduce so fast!
Some of them eat bugs, right?
So like...
Oh god, okay.
So like all we do is we...
Oh wait, I see it.
I see it.
It's his tail.
Oh my god.
My tail theory.
It's the tail theory, guys.
All over again.
Okay.
It's the tail theory.
We climbed the tail.
Oh my god.
Please for the love of god.
Maybe I'll swim faster than the weight.
Maybe if I swim faster, it'll work.
Oh my god.
I fucking knew it's the tail.
All right, here you go.
Here you go.
I knew it.
I knew it was going to be the tail.
It's always the tail.
That's true.
It's just the theory.
Tail theory.
Oh, I'm seeing.
Like salamanders, they just eat bugs, right?
And bugs reproduce crazy fucking fast.
So like if you're hungry, give the salamander bugs and then...
What?
Where is it?
Where the fuck is it?
Why does he have like teeth on his head?
Where do I take him?
Why is he at like...
What?
Why is there teeth on his head?
That's not where you're supposed to go.
Why do you have teeth on your head?
Oh god.
No shit.
Oh shit!
Okay.
Oh, that's gotta hurt if you hit the tooth straight on.
Oh, I can steer it!
Like a steering wheel!
It's like my very own car.
Bro, this is better than a horse.
Although I don't mean it.
You know that because I still need you.
You know I don't mean it.
It's like a xylophone teeth.
I don't know.
I don't want to do this.
Can I like take him to like the other claw?
I assume I have to go here, right?
Like where else would I fucking go?
Now I'm a dent...
Guys, now I'm a licensed dentist now.
Guys, I'm here to...
Look at all these cavities!
Bro!
You need a dentures!
Or braces!
Honestly, you definitely need braces.
This tooth is like so fucking overgrown.
Like holy shit.
You 100% need a fucking dentist.
What do I do?
I'm gonna go to the dentist.
I'm up here now.
Hello?
What do I do?
I'm here.
What are you doing?
Oh, what are you doing?
Oh my god!
You're giving me your belly?
What do I do here?
Oh!
Oh my god!
Okay guys, he needs a belly rub.
Isn't that cute?
Guys, he needs a little belly rub here.
Don't worry.
Those juices are just all the oil from excitement.
Oh shit!
Fuck!
Okay.
Don't worry, I'm okay.
I'm okay guys.
I'm okay.
I just gave him a little belly rub and he got a little too excited.
Guys, come on.
Let me through.
It's like a dentist, like... Okay, if a dentist gives you belly rub, that is not a licensed dentist.
Just saying.
But I'm different.
I'm different.
I'm a specialist.
If a dentist, after your procedure, tries to give you belly rubs, I don't think that's a real dentist guys.
I think... I think...
I think you might... I think you might got scammed.
Unless... Unless it's jokey.
Unless it's jokey.
I'm a specialist.
It's like my thing.
It's like, you know, children dentists where like, there's dentists that are just primarily for kids.
And they have these like weird ass offices.
Like, kid themed dentist offices.
I was watching a video where there was a dentist...
There was a dentist that specializes on just children.
And then, the thing is like, their entire office...
Was like, they have an elevator in their office.
Like, in the procedure room to entertain kids.
And I'm like, Jesus fucking...
Like, they have an actual like, mini elevator.
Where...
Where they do like, some Willy Wonka shit.
Some Willy Wonka shit to like, make the kids feel comfortable.
But it's still like, fucking crazy.
Oh god.
Oh...
Sir, I know you have...
You gotta stop eating candy!
Look at your overgrown teeth!
It's like they're...
Oh!
Okay, I'm okay.
I didn't...
I didn't ply anything.
Alright, here we go.
And climb.
That was close.
I'm holding on for dear life right now.
I don't know what you're talking about, guys.
I don't know what you're talking about.
This is how dentists works.
You guys might not know, because you don't see your own mouth.
This is what the dentist looks like when you're fixing...
When they're fixing your teeth.
You just smack it until something happens.
Jesus Christ.
Turn around.
Keep turning.
Who keeps hitting my cavities?
This is why they put like, those...
Those like, anesthesia...
No, not anesthesia.
What are those things that make your fucking mouth numb?
This is what they do.
You just whack it.
I love my Eldritch Horror Dentist area.
That should be it, right?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
That's fine.
We're fine.
Alright, you want a little belly rub?
After getting rid of that cavity, you need that little belly rub?
Don't worry.
I'm a specialist.
Every time I fix a teeth, I give a belly rub.
To make you feel better.
I wonder if dog dentists...
I wonder like...
If you get paid more to be a dog dentist than a regular dentist.
Because like, I feel like vets can make so much more money...
Than like, like any...
Oh!
No!
My platform!
How would I give you the belly rub?
Ooh, tummy hurt.
How would I give you the belly rub, sir?
Guys, it's because I did too much of a good job.
It's not because my belly rubs were fucking shit.
There's another platform?
Oh my god.
I need to swim again.
Swim, swim, swim.
No.
I need to swim more.
Sir, I can't keep give...
I can't give you belly rubs or you destroy my platform.
All I'm saying is that I feel like your profession is like animal related.
You get paid so much more.
Only because I feel like...
Because like...
We love our pets so fucking much that we will like...
Oh my god.
He like...
Just fixed his back too.
We love our pets so much more...
That we will spend a lot of money.
Especially for like...
Dog dentistry.
There you go.
Sir, we haven't fixed your teeth yet.
We gotta give you braces on the head.
Sir.
How the fuck did you like...
Get cavities on your head?
What are you eating?
Oh my god, please.
Where's the other platform?
I don't even know where the other...
Oh, it's over there.
It's on the right side.
All right.
Here you go.
We may give you adult braces.
Don't worry.
Some people are into that.
Oh shit.
Sorry for laughing.
Down you go.
Oops, sorry.
I went the wrong way.
My GPS isn't working.
All right.
Here you go.
Oh fuck.
Okay, sorry.
I said sorry.
I'm sorry.
Sorry for hitting the fucking gums.
I said, sorry.
Look, you wanted the cheap dentist.
Okay.
Look, you could have got a real dentist that only specialises on teeth.
But you got the chiropractor, dentist, acupuncturist, massage parlour, and uterus.
That's not my fault.
You could have went for the real deal.
I am real.
But he could have went for the actual specialist dentist.
I'm the one with the... being good at a lot.
Like, being decent at a lot of things means that you're not good at one thing.
So all I'm saying is that I might not have as much time doing head teeth versus like massage... massages.
Jack of all trades... yeah, exactly!
Jack of all trades, master of no... EXACTLY!
Look, it doesn't... I might be able to have a license on all of them, but it doesn't mean I am the best at all.
Guys... I just have a certificate.
I like passed.
It doesn't mean I got a good grade.
It just means I passed.
Hahaha!
It just means like that.
Yay!
Another happy client!
Speaking of cheap specialists, did you see Conan and Brian's Hot Ones episode where he brought that totally legit doctor with him?
Long time.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I wanna watch his stuff.
He's like... he's really... I think like any comedian...
Cause like I feel like in order to like...
Master comedy, you have to be like really smart.
I feel like...
Dude, you're so easy to know.
Like a lot of like really good... cause like it's so com... like universal comedy like things that make people...
Who the fuck are these people?
Are they trying to encroach on my territory?
Guys, I claim this territory.
This is my...
Neuter massage... acupuncturist... uh... dentist area.
I claim that.
It's like... it's like gangs.
Like this is my turf.
What the fuck are you doing?
Get out of my turf.
But I feel like... like... cause you have to be smart to be able to... be able to write humor that's like funny.
That's universally funny.
Um... and like... especially humor that sort of transcends like... uh... transcends like... uh... language barriers.
And like a lot of my favorite comedians... Yeah, to write good humor... A lot of my favorite comedians...
I went to our Ivy League graduates too.
And I feel like a good comedian actor can be an amazing...
can be like... what is this?
The Fast...
Desert!
Oh no.
Not the desert.
Not the fucking dry lakes.
I feel like a lot of comedians are really good actors in general.
Because you have to be a really good actor to make comedy movies work.
To make a comedy movie seem natural.
I feel like.
Especially improv too.
You have to be really smart to be able to do improv correctly.
Because there can be super cringe improv.
I feel like a lot of super good actors...
like super good comedian actors...
can actually be really good actors.
In general.
Adam Sandler, my favorite actor.
Okay, when Adam Sandler actually does drama...
He's a really good actor.
But he just gets paid more being a comedian.
Because he just like...
He doesn't do indie movie films a lot.
Or drama.
Because indie films and movie films...
don't pay as much.
And because of that...
Because of that he just does...
He just does like comedies.
Because he gets a bigger deal.
Like gets a bigger like move...
Gets a bigger pay...
Like a bigger pay cut.
Because if you think like...
If you think like...
Like the Netflix deal he had...
That paid so much money.
And then you're like...
Okay like that movie he did...
A pixel.
You know the worst fucking Adam...
One of the worst fucking Adam Sandler movie of all time.
He basically hired all his friends.
So like that they get free paid vacation.
He literally did that movie...
So he could get like a free paid vacation.
Because he doesn't care.
He just wants to have like...
He just here to fucking make money...
To support his family.
And his friends.
Yeah all he does is just hire his friends.
So his friends can get paid.
And also...
And also like...
He can get paid as well.
I can't forgive him for Pixar.
But then when he does like drama movies...
He's actually really...
Like I like watched Uncut Gems.
But I could only watch up to like...
A certain point.
Because it was just...
So good.
And like...
It is like...
You know when a movie is...
Like for me when a movie is too good...
And depressing.
I just stop watching.
Because I got too fucking depressed watching it.
I was just like...
Oh my god this feels too real.
And then I stopped watching it.
Because it was way too real.
And I was like bro I'm getting really sad.
And then I stopped.
But it was good.
It was a good movie.
But like I was just...
Super anxious watching it.
Because it was so fucking high tension.
And then...
It was like super high tension.
And then like super depressing.
And I had to stop watching it.
Because it was actually too good.
But yeah.
That's honestly what I believe.
I feel like comedians are like...
A lot of comedians are like comedy actors.
And actresses are like really good at acting in general.
Because it takes a lot of skill to make comedy movies work in general.
Because like you gotta...
You have to try to make it not cringe.
Like what's your name?
Is it Kate McKinnon?
Oh my gosh.
Where the fuck do I go?
Where is the desert?
Is it Kate McKinnon that...
I'm trying to remember.
No, not Kate McKinnon.
There's the other one.
The other one...
Before Kate McKinnon.
There's the other one.
I'm trying to remember.
There was this female actress.
That's like been in a lot of comedy films.
The wife of the guy who's in Despicable...
Okay.
I'm trying to remember what other role she did.
But all I can remember is the wife of...
Oh, Kristen Wiig!
Yes!
Kristen Wiig!
Okay, you know Kristen Wiig?
In a lot of like...
In a lot of like comedy films.
But she has done like some drama stuff.
They're like sort of indies though.
They're like indie films.
But she's such a good actress.
I watched like...
There was like one she did where she was like...
Like pretending to...
Like not pretending.
She was like a twin sister of Bill Hader or something.
Like that was the plot.
And like...
Also Bill Hader too.
Bill Hader in that movie where he's the assassin.
That one was really good as well.
Not movie.
That TV series where he was like...
He plays an assassin.
He's such a good actor.
Barry!
Yes!
I love that show.
That show was really good.
Look, I just really love comedians.
Because I think...
I think comedians are like...
Are like super talented in general.
And a lot of them are actually like crazy smart.
I think I...
Did I not fucking ate the salamander in this one already?
I feel like I did.
Cause like, I don't see that salamander.
Where the fuck is the sal...
No.
I must've eaten the salamander.
Did I eat this guy already?
I feel like I have the..
I have.
I don't see him.
I don't hear the plip plop of his feet.
I've been here?
Yeah, I have.
I've been here already.
Okay.
Yeah.
Like this place has been discovered already.
I don't hear the plop plop of the feet too, so I think I ate them.
I ate his family already.
Oh no, I'm lost now.
Oh no, there's no GPS.
Sun GPS, where are you when I needed you the most?
Sun GPS.
Where are you?
Where am I?
Sun GPS?
Okay, this way.
Okay, there's a little sun GPS right there.
I think it's this way.
Right?
Where else can it be?
Okay, a little hole.
There, it's this way.
I found the little hole for my sun GPS... for my sword GPS.
It has to be this way.
Where else could it be?
Yeah, it's this way.
Alright, we're good to go.
I've been here before.
No.
This way.
Okay.
Arlo, I figured it out!
Arlo, come over here!
I found the exit!
Arlo!
I did it!
Guys, I think... oh wait, no, I can climb up, right?
Wait a minute.
Why is there no up?
Hahaha!
Wait a minute.
Why is it just tree here?
Hahaha!
Well, at least I can eat the fruit.
Maybe... I'll just eat the fruit then.
Okay, fine, right?
Fruit time.
Woop!
Wait, wouldn't that like drop to the water?
Ah!
Oh yeah, it did.
Oh, yeah, it did.
Wait, how the f- oh, wait, it did.
Okay.
That was useless.
That's... that was fucking useless.
The fuck?
How the fuck do I get up?
Why does this lead me to nowhere?
Oh, wait, can I go up from here?
Why does this lead me...
Wait, what?
Where do I go?
Do I go down?
Is that it?
Maybe.
There's no way it's not down, right?
Down is up.
You've learned that.
Yeah, see, I'm okay.
Down is up.
But where do I go?
Hahaha!
Where did that poop go?
Guys, I don't know if I should have went down.
Hahaha!
Guys, I don't know.
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Up is up?
Guys, I don't know if down is up anymore.
Guys, we're...
Am I supposed to be here?
This is the opposite of a desert.
Hahaha!
Guys, I don't know.
This does not feel like the desert to me.
Hahaha!
Guys, I don't know.
This definitely does not feel like a desert.
Hahaha!
It's like here, but how do I get there?
Is it over there?
The wet desert.
Hahaha!
Guys, I don't think I'm supposed to be here.
Maybe I'm supposed to go here?
Hahaha!
Where the fuck am I supposed to go?
It's on the other side.
Did you see it?
Hahaha!
Am I supposed to be here?
Wait, Arlo?
Is that you, Arlo?
What the fuck?
How did you get here?
Am I supposed to be in the wet swamps?
But it said, like, desert.
I can't tell anymore.
Hahaha!
I can't tell.
But, no.
It's not here.
It's past this?
It's right there?
Oh, there's trees though.
Where the fuck am I supposed to go?
Oh, God.
Where's the sun?
You need to go up.
Okay, I have to go up.
Was I going the right way earlier?
Wait, is there an up here?
Maybe there's an up here.
This is the hardest part.
I spend more time finding the goddamn colossi than I- Oh, wait!
It's up here!
Is that Kay?
That's like...
away.
Hahaha!
But isn't that away from the destination?
I don't- Is this it?
Is this the right colossi?
Up is down, therefore wet is desert.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is it?
I'm in a cave.
Keep going and stay left.
Is this left?
Cave.
Maybe.
I think I went the right way.
Wait, is that desert?
Oh my God!
Down is up!
Neat!
Thank you for the feedback!
I knew it!
I fucking knew!
I fucking knew it!
Down is always- I can't believe I second guessed myself.
I can't believe it!
Chat, I knew my gut was right.
Down is always up.
Down is- It's never wrong!
Down is up!
Oh my God, you're a fucking genius, Doki.
You always knew which way is up.
You always knew.
You always knew which way was up, Doki.
How does she do it?
Where is this guy?
Oh no, my son's GPS is not working right now.
Where the fuck is it?
Yeah, my son's GPS is not doing so well.
I guess I'll go forward?
It has to be forward, right?
Where else could it be?
I passed it?
How do you pass the desert?
It's a fucking desert!
Other way?
But it's a goddamn desert!
It's not this.
Guys,
it was this.
Guys, apparently it was.
Bro, what the fuck?
It has like duck lips.
Oh my God, he has like fucking...
There's like air sacs on his chest.
Like frogs.
Like multiple balls.
Oh no, do I need the horse for this?
Do I need Arlo?
Arlo, I've always believed in you.
Arlo.
Please, I've always believed in you, Arlo.
Sand bird.
I feel like it's a sand frog.
Because it has like those little pouches.
It's like these little pouches on his stomach.
What do I do?
Do I poke his belly?
Poke his balls?
Did I hit it?
I can't tell.
Or do I actually have to steer it?
Oh God.
I hate this already.
Oh yeah, they do.
Some birds do.
Because it's like some fucking...
Like those like...
Like girlfriend dances.
Where they like puff themselves up for a female.
And stuff.
Shoot the pouch.
Okay.
Who ain't finding a girlfriend?
That's fucking right.
No girlfriend for you.
Who ain't finding no girl?
If I have anything to do with it.
No girl.
No girlfriend.
Oh my God.
I feel like we need this shot.
Jesus Christ.
No!
That's so fucked up!
That's right.
Deflate the sacks.
Deflate the sacks!
Doki the veterinarian is back!
There is a bird problem!
There you go.
You don't deserve to be in the sky.
Only one person can deserve...
deserves to be in the sky and that's me.
Alright, I deflated it.
No sky for you.
No girlfriend for you, man.
Oh, I think I have to jump.
I have to jump on that, don't I?
Arlo, please.
Please be faster, Arlo.
Please.
No!
I know!
Bro, this fucking boss sucks.
Bro, this fucking boss fight fucking sucks.
This has to be the worst boss.
This 100% has to be the worst boss.
Because I don't know how to do this.
Bro, please, Arlo.
Please!
You can fucking ride faster than this, Arlo.
Please...
Oh!
Is that a skill issue?
I don't know what you mean.
Yes!
Oh!
I did it!
I DID IT!
Skillet shoot my ass!
There we go.
It was just- it's Arlo's!
It's Arlo's fault!
There's no way!
Never blame yourself when you're gaming.
No, no, no, no, please, please!
Here we go.
Okay.
I need my sword.
Where is the thing?
Oh, fuck!
Okay!
I'm gonna go get my sword.
There's no way he's gonna do a backflip.
Oh, there it is!
It's hidden back here!
Alright, it's back to my regular job of being an acupuncturist.
Finally!
Oh my god!
Bro, the economy was not nice to me, man.
I had to take to get so many other different jobs.
But this is what I'm passionate about!
Stabbing people's back until they like it.
Okay, where's the other flap, though?
Oh, no.
Where could the other flap be?
Behind?
It has to be on the tail, right?
Oh, god.
It's flat.
What?
Okay.
We're okay.
I just gotta walk up.
He's not gonna do the flip!
Oh, he's not.
He didn't do the flip, guys.
He didn't do the flip.
It has to be back here, right?
Oh, yes.
I knew it.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
Where is your license?
What?
Oh, he like closed it!
Wait, do I have to deflate his sacs again?
Open up!
Oh, wait.
Did I hit it?
Did I hit everything?
Guys,
do you think he liked it?
Look, after every acupuncture...
After every acupuncture session, he has to take a mud bath.
So, like, the mud will fill up the holes and patch it up, you know?
So, you know how, like, I poked holes into his body?
So, now, he has to go take a mud bath to cleanse his skin of all the...
of all the excess toxins.
And then the mud will fill up the holes and...
Where did he go?
And the mud will fill up his holes.
And so, like, it will, like, block out all the bacteria outside.
Don't worry.
I'm a specialist.
Oh my god, he reclued his sacs.
Bro.
How many times do I have to teach you, old man?
Can't have a girlfriend.
Okay!
Oh, am I okay?
I can't
think I was okay.
I don't know.
Guys.
I'm okay, guys.
Don't worry.
We're fine.
Did they grow bigger?
It's like a pimple.
You pop the pimple and it comes back bigger.
The horse rotate.
Oh my god.
Bro, you're not having a girlfriend!
You can't afford a girlfriend right now!
You gotta work on yourself before you can work on having a girlfriend!
Oh my god.
It's time to deflate.
No more girlfriend for you.
It's time to deflate the sacs.
Please.
How am I not hitting?
That's so real.
Alright.
I know.
We need to get there closer.
Don't keep...
Look.
I'm here to give you a life lesson, man.
Look at you.
Where do you...
You live in the fucking desert?
Bro.
Do you really think this is the way to go?
Sir?
You live in the goddamn desert?
Okay.
That has to be like close enough, right?
There you go.
I deflated one of the sacs.
I'm gonna go back.
Alright.
We gotta get closer to the other one.
Sac number two.
Oh wait.
Sac behind me.
I almost forgot this one.
Eventually I'll hit it.
Eventually.
Yeah!
Do it!
You don't...
You miss...
You hit the shots you take eventually.
You just gotta keep shooting.
Oh no.
Is he going back to take his mud bath?
Are the sacs gonna be deflated again?
Is it filled with sand?
Oh no.
Where is he going?
Not again.
Guys, I don't wanna do the flip again.
Can I climb up from here?
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'll grab this one.
Eventually I can hit.
Arlo, please.
Arlo!
Okay.
Nice.
That must be a hit.
There we go.
We got it.
We got it, Ma.
No more girlfriend.
Alright.
Here we go.
This is it.
Practice this.
Right here.
Right now, Arlo.
God damn it, Arlo!
I said right here, right now!
Arlo!
Right here, right now!
Yeah!
Okay.
This time.
Alright.
Where the fuck is he?
We can't do this.
Right here.
Right now.
It's not my fault, guys!
Arlo just doesn't take directions quite well yet!
It's like our first time!
Arlo, please.
Don't blame the horse.
Blame the rider.
How about it's both our faults, okay?
How about that?
Is that better?
It's both our faults, okay guys?
Okay, we're done.
We both take blame!
It's me and Arlo's fault!
Oh, God.
Climb up.
Yay!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Come on, come on!
Go to the other side!
Come on!
Yes!
Okay, where is the other one?
Is it like back here?
I don't remember which one I fucking hit.
There's like so many fins.
Okay.
Oh, it's behind.
It's in the back.
Alright, it is in the back.
Oh, there it is!
There it is!
Here we go!
And...
Ha!
Alright, several more shots.
Don't worry, it's my passion!
It has to be like one more.
What the fuck?
Oh!
Oh, I already finished all of them.
Please grab onto it.
I don't know which one I haven't done yet, sir!
You have so many sore spots!
It has to be the back, right?
Oh my god, where am I?
Oh my god, it's his butt.
Oh my god, god.
Sir, you need to stop.
Buy a better chair.
Sir.
Oh!
Oh my god.
That scared me.
Sir, please.
Sir, you can't keep sitting on those chairs.
No!
Sir, I'm trying to help you!
You can't keep sitting on those chairs!
You're sitting on these cheap plastic chairs forever!
Please!
Open up!
No!
Alright, guys.
Guys, I don't think he wants...
Guys, he's just taking another mud bath.
Oh my god.
Not a round three.
Not a fucking round three.
This is dirt bath time.
He's like a fucking chinchilla.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Here we go again.
You can and will.
Sir!
You have to keep...
You have to fucking let me massage the ass!
God, poke the ass and let out the stress!
You have to get better chairs!
You gotta stop fucking buying those cheap plastic chairs!
Those long chairs!
They're not good for your butt.
At least put a cushion on it!
One more time.
Alright.
I swear to god if I have...
Sir, please.
I told you.
Now is not the right time to have a girlfriend.
Stop doing...
Nobody's watching.
No female...
No female is watching your dance right now, sir!
You gotta work on yourself first before you do all of this!
Please!
You literally live in the goddamn desert!
Look, I am a professional.
It's acupuncture is first before female.
I am...
very passionate about my job.
Oh my god.
Do not look at the way I aim right now.
There you go.
Alright.
Oh my god.
This has to be my toughest client yet.
Bro.
You're getting charged extra, man.
I'm gonna put all those hidden fees like a hotel.
Alright.
I'm gonna put all those hidden fees in that fucking bill soon.
Okay, we gotta...
We gotta climb up again.
I'm doki, bro.
Look, it's not my fault he's a tough client.
Alright?
He's just a really tough client right now.
Are you fucking...
No.
Please!
God damn it.
This is the worst.
He's gonna use young girls to choose to live in the desert.
He just can't.
Bro, the red is just insane.
He's just gonna use young girls to choose to live in the desert.
It's like almost like New York City.
Oh my god.
Please.
The hardest part is just jumping onto these fucking things.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god.
What are you...
I hate this.
I hate this one.
There's gonna be so many hidden fees.
I'm gonna try to like triple the price and then I'm gonna ask for a discount.
Come on, come on, come on.
Please, Arlo.
No!
I can't.
Why is he so fucking...
Why
is he so fucking...
Why is he so fucking...
Guys.
For all you bot watchers, you might have to skip this.
I'm gonna wait like five minutes into the stream.
For all the bot watchers.
Just wait like five more minutes and then we'll get there.
I swear.
Just wait five more minutes.
Okay.
What?
Fucking
air pouches again.
I have a feeling.
Oh.
There's no way.
I fucking gripped it.
Keep
going.
Keep going.
We have to keep going.
We fucking delayed so much that we gotta head to the ass.
Please.
Head to the butt.
Get to the butt.
It's the only way.
It's so far from the ass.
Oh my god.
It's so fucking far.
Why are you so long?
Okay.
It's way too long, man.
Alright, here we go.
God, it's just all body.
No ass.
Please.
Worst appointment ever.
Don't call me back.
We will never fix your stress again.
A lot of collapse.
This is the worst one.
I'm gonna fucking charge so many hidden fees.
Worst customer.
I'm banning him.
I'm gonna take a picture and then put him on the banned list.
You know those convenience stores where they're like never servicing that person again?
That's him.
Bro.
You're the worst client I've ever had.
Everybody else was so nice.
This was my passion too.
I can't believe I'm not getting paid for this.
I can't believe it.
You ruined my passion.
Wes, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So that was your favorite one, right?
Ban forever.
Don't call back.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ban from life.
Alright, nice.
It's so nice that they always transport me back to my home.
Look at that.
See?
They love this.
They love my work so much.
Please take me back home.
Isn't that great?
Oh my god.
Please tell me I don't have to drive the horse anymore.
Please.
Please tell me that was the last time I have to drive the horse.
Please for the love of god.
A guardian set loose.
A closed off city beyond the channel.
Where's that?
Is that not desert?
Lust for destruction.
Okay, it's not the desert.
That's a win in my book.
No desert.
No desert win.
Win time.
Yeah!
No desert!
Let's go!
No more deserts!
Let's fucking go!
As long as there's no more deserts.
That's all that matters.
Senpai, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Pray to save.
Pray to save?
Let me pray.
There you go.
A doki shoutout from Brazil!
My belly hurts from laughing at that sassy tomato girl.
Tell me any plans on playing Splatoon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Definitely in the future.
I know there's Splatfest tomorrow.
Because two of my friends, they're like S++ rank.
Like the highest rank possible.
Is it X rank?
Oh wait, it's X rank, right?
The highest rank possible.
And they invited me to do some Splatfest.
But I was like, guys, I haven't played Splatoon in a long time.
So we're gonna do it off stream.
Because they're like hardcore Splatoon players.
You guys might know them.
Poki and GG.
And you might know who they are.
I know who the two artists are.
Because they're like really...
They've done a lot of famous artworks for Hololive.
I know Poki has done a lot of well-known art pieces.
For...
For Holo and Demon Dice.
If you guys know her music videos and stuff.
And...
You know Poki?
Like the Poki Pokums?
Yeah, yeah.
They invited me to play some Splatoon off stream.
They were deciding whether to do it off stream or on stream.
And...
You know like the artwork where...
When they debut, she would draw these artworks.
Where it's like...
Pokemon cutouts and stuff.
With like the faces and the little chibis in the bottom.
Like they're like really famous artwork in the Hololive community.
And...
And also she's done artwork for music video artworks.
For Demon Dice and stuff.
Um...
She's done really amazing artwork.
And like GT is like the Xenoblade fanatic.
And she's like done...
She has done like a lot of famous...
Xenoblade artwork and stuff.
Like fan art and stuff.
As well as like drawing some...
Some...
Drawing some like...
Popular artwork for Holo too.
And like they invited me to play some Splatoon.
Offline.
Or offline online.
And I was like you guys are too good.
I was like... guys.
You guys are too good.
We play off stream and then next time we play on stream.
Because I...
Because they're like the highest rank possible in Splatoon.
I was like... guys.
Guys...
We play off stream and then next time we play on stream.
Together.
Because...
You guys are too good.
Um...
But they're really amazing people.
They recommended me...
Recommended me like some manufacturers for merch and stuff.
Because they're like really well known in the artist alley scene.
And...
And they're like...
I was asking them for like recommendations.
For like some manufacturers.
Like plushies and other stuff too.
Because they've like made plushies in the past.
With artist alley.
So it's great too.
Asking them for...
It's nice having like artist friends.
Especially artist friends that does like artist alley and stuff.
Because... um...
When you're level 99 friend invite the level 3 friend.
Yeah!
That's me!
Because like...
They know all the...
Fucking good manufacturers.
Instead of like the bad ones.
So I can ask them for recommendations and stuff.
Um...
Instead of like trial and error.
Some manufacturers.
Anyway.
Sorry I can't multitask.
I'm so bad at multitasking.
Where the fuck do I go?
Okay it's this way.
Alright.
We go this way.
Sorry I couldn't have that fucking...
Zatsu.
Because I was so bad at...
Multitasking.
Um...
But yeah I've been friends with them.
Like...
For a very long time.
Like when I was just a really small streamer.
Because like...
Where the fuck do I go?
Is it across the map again?
It has to be.
It's across the map.
I've been friends with them like...
For a long long...
For a while now.
Before...
Before you know I started...
Like actually Vtubing.
Um...
I think like we met when we were like art streamers.
When we did like art and stuff.
And like I noticed that like...
They know Cantonese.
And stuff.
So I was like...
Oh my god!
You know Cantonese?
I know Cantonese!
And then we like...
Responded over that.
And we like...
Rated each other.
And we were like super small art streamers.
And then you know...
Like we've been friends because of that.
Like we're like...
You speak the same language!
I speak the same language!
And then...
That's how we like met.
Yeah like when we were all like small...
Art streamers and stuff.
We like...
Rated each other.
I think it was like before Vtubers were a thing too.
Like not Vtubers.
Before like...
Before like HoloEN ever like...
Debut and stuff.
And like Vtubers were still like...
A new concept.
In the western side.
Have I been to that shrine before?
Can't tell.
Yes?
I can't tell.
Oh my god.
I can't tell if I've been to that one.
Oh my god!
We both...
We're like same hat.
Same hat!
Jesus Christ.
Arlo sometimes I wish you can just jump across this cliff.
Like can't you do a cool trick like this?
Arlo?
Come on Arlo.
Why can't you do cool tricks like that?
Okay it's this way.
Alright it's this way.
Yay!
Have I been to that shrine?
I must have.
That's like a shrine in the middle of fucking nowhere.
Wait have I?
No I haven't.
It hasn't been activated.
Oh wait.
I haven't activated this fucking shrine.
It's like in the middle of nowhere.
Alex!
Thank you for the farm!
Get the chips!
Thank you!
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome welcome!
Okay she rolled her R's.
No.
Absolutely.
This is like the closest.
Everyone always makes fun of me.
Because I can't roll my R's.
Okay.
I can't!
There he is.
Little pipa.
That's like the closest I can to like rolling my R's.
Look I'm trying my best here!
What the fuck?
Where the fuck did he go?
Where does the- Oh there he is.
Okay let me grab my bow.
Gamer.
Still alive.
Still.
There you go.
Not alive anymore.
Okay this is like.
I just want to test my theory out.
About like if we can do an infinite food glitch with salamanders.
It's like okay.
Like I'm just saying.
If they can like you know.
It's like you can eat worms and stuff.
Right?
Like.
It's like what was it?
Do you know that like children's book about eating worms?
God what was it?
They always make you read that fucking book.
That old book about eating worms and stuff.
Uh.
What is the cud?
What is that cud?
That worm.
How to eat fried worms?
Yes!
Yes it's just like that!
I'm just saying.
We can fix.
Like it might not be.
Like if we can like put like.
Cause we can have.
Technically we can have infinite food.
Food glitch with worms.
If you think about it.
And like it's all about how you season the worms.
You know?
Okay it's this way.
I'm going to do the jump.
Goodbye Ido.
Wee!
There's no way I die.
See I'm fine.
I eat so much fruit.
That I'm fine.
Like that.
Speedrun.
I'm just saying.
Okay well no you just raise the children.
Off of a worm only diet.
So they never know what actually tastes good.
Like.
It's just all about like the seasoning.
If you have.
Put good enough seasoning.
It'll eventually taste good.
And then all you have to do.
Is just like.
It's so funny.
I'm so fucked up.
It's still food.
The child has no concept of what is good food.
You raise him like a bird.
You mean.
It's still food.
I don't.
That's so cruel.
Okay look.
Salamander tails and worms.
Is that better?
They're a healthy diet.
That's enough meat.
I'm going to eat this.
Right?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's enough meat.
Where the fuck do I go?
No that's not it.
Most normal.
Dirty tangent.
Mike thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's not it.
I'm just trying to figure out how to like.
Do the infinite food glitch.
Are you not curious out of science?
For science.
You do not care about science.
Scientific reasoning.
Why don't we just farm real animals?
Because you can't do it.
Because when you farm real animals.
Okay are you trying to say worms are not real?
Worms deserve like.
Rights too.
Like okay the thing about farming real animals.
Is that you have to.
Where the fuck do I get across?
The thing about farming real animals.
Is that eventually.
Like it takes too long.
To farm them.
That's the whole issue.
Real animals just take too long to farm.
But like.
But like if you like cut a worm.
And like or like you know grab it.
And sell it man.
They eventually regrow it in there.
Like multiple times.
So like all I'm saying.
Is like starfish.
We can eat starfish too.
Because they can regrow their limbs.
Think about it.
We just eat the animals that can regrow themselves.
Guys think about it.
And then we don't have to worry about like.
We don't have to build more farms.
To like.
Guys think about it.
We don't have to build more farms.
To fix like the.
Like you know.
We don't have to demolish more forests.
To build more farms.
To build more like.
Okay so what about the vegans and the vegetarians.
Well.
What about.
I guess we'll grow fruit.
I don't know.
I'm thinking about like.
The meat lover.
The meat lover problems right now.
We'll tackle vegans and vegetarians.
Another time.
This is about like.
We're tackling problems one at a time.
Guys.
There's too many problems in the world.
Okay.
Thank you.
That's what.
That's why we're talking about.
The stomach scenario.
Okay.
Where do I go?
Do I go straight?
Am I going the right way?
Is it up?
It has to be up right?
I feel like I'm not going the right way.
Is this the right way?
Up I believe.
I don't know.
I don't even know guys.
I don't know if I'm going the right way.
To the left?
Have I been here?
Yeah I have.
Is it left side?
This floor.
I need to figure out where to go.
It's like here.
I guess like this way?
It's close to the.
Which fish?
I've like fucking killed so many like aquatic creatures.
Is it this way?
Am I going the right way guys?
I can't tell.
It has to be the right way.
Eight hours.
I'm going the right way.
Eight hours later.
This has to be the right way.
Right?
Yeah.
Yeah yeah yeah.
I think I'm so smart.
I think I'm right.
I think I solved world hunger.
Guys.
If people aren't like pussies about eating worms and salamanders.
We'll be fine.
Like eat worms or 600k Scoville chicken with fish.
No milk.
Oh 100% the 600k Scoville chicken.
Cause that shit is like not that spicy to me.
Yeah.
All I'm saying is that people are cowards.
People are fucking cowards.
There's just not.
Who cares about what a food tastes like.
It's all about getting your proteins.
Right?
As long as we get our proteins in.
We're fucking rich.
We're fucking fine.
Why do you guys care about what a food tastes like?
Butoki why don't you try it out then?
Look okay.
I can't like lead by example if no one else wants to like lead with me.
Okay this is a group effort.
I can't do this on my own.
Guys.
It's all about working together.
You first.
Look.
We're here to work together.
It's not a race here.
It's about teamwork.
It's our ideas.
We cooked this idea together.
It's not your idea.
It's our ideas.
Together.
Cause we're a team.
Dragons.
You and I.
We're a team.
What happened to being a team?
Guys we came up with this idea together.
You do not want to solve world hunger?
That's fucked up chat.
Yes Doki.
Manipulation.
That's so healthy.
Manipulation and gaslighting.
We did it.
Alright here we go.
This is it.
Where is he?
Where the fuck is the guy?
Where do I go?
Where the fuck is the colossi?
Oh it's here.
There's like a little hole here.
Down the hole we go.
A red flower.
What the fuck am I gonna do with a red flower?
Where is this guy anyway?
Oh there he is.
Oh my god he's like a guard dog.
I've killed his brother.
I mean I've...
I gave his brother a belly rub.
Hello.
What do I do?
Is he gonna like knock me over again?
What the fuck do I do?
Sir.
Sir what is your problem?
What problems do you have sir?
Oh my god he can jump.
What the fuck do I do?
What's that?
Hello?
Phew.
I'm right here sir.
What the fuck do I do?
He has no heart.
Can I climb this?
Oh no.
I don't know what to do.
What the fuck do I do?
Oh shit.
Oh what the fuck?
Oh wait I'm okay.
Wait that didn't hurt.
Wait I'm okay.
Oh please.
Okay never mind that hurt.
Alright guys.
I fouled up.
Please get up.
It's just a little concussion.
Get up.
Oh he did it.
Oh thank god.
Okay.
Parkour.
Climb something?
This?
Oh do I climb this?
And then I jump over there?
I think so.
Right?
Wait let's go down climb.
Thank god.
Okay.
Parkour.
Okay it's parkour time.
Watch this.
Up foot.
Weee.
Okay and then I climb up.
Now what do I do?
I'm king of the world.
Heard a reboot in king of the hill.
Alright what are we gonna do?
I have the high ground now.
The fuck are you gonna do about it huh?
That's fucking right.
Nothing.
Cause I'm taller than you.
If you're taller, you're smarter.
Hello?
What are you doing?
What the fuck do I do up here?
I thought I fell.
I shot the ass.
We actually made it.
Where's the other platform?
Oh my god.
Did you guys see that?
I actually made the jump.
The cutscene jump.
What the fuck.
Gaming.
That's when you know I'm a gamer.
Get yourself a doki that can fucking do the cutscene jump.
Did you see it?
Circle emoji.
Is that it?
Woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah.
Do I have to do another jump here?
Later?
Do I have to do a cutscene jump?
Alright come on.
Come on.
Do it again.
Now I'm a...
Now I'm a professional parkour artist.
I have many jobs.
I'm shooting the butt again.
That's right.
What are you gonna do about it huh?
That's fucking right.
Come on.
Charge me.
Get in my face.
Oh shit.
Weeee.
I actually thought I was gonna miss.
Alright here we go again.
Come on.
Do it again.
It'll be so funny.
Come on.
It'll be so fucking funny.
I'm so old.
You guys.
Guys, I don't think he thought it was funny.
I don't think he thought it was funny, guys.
I don't know why, but I think he thought it was funny.
Last minute save.
I told you I'm a professional parkour artist.
Another one.
Where do I jump from here?
Like there?
I guess there, right?
There's no more areas to jump to.
Again, again!
Again, come on bro!
Why are you so fucking pussy?
Your
wife left you!
Okay, nice.
And then we jump from here.
Alright.
Up we go.
Come on sir!
What do you do again?
We gotta fix your concussion too.
We all know to fix your concussion you just gotta keep...
It's like amnesia.
You know?
You hit your head again, you remember everything.
When you get concussion, you just...
Guys, don't follow my deco...
I'm not a doctor.
I might be like licensed in many things, but doctor isn't it.
Just so you know.
Just so you guys know.
We might have a lot of licenses in multiple things.
But anyway, as I was saying...
We're gonna fix your concussion sir!
This is like non-licensed medical advice.
But like, you know, I think...
In my opinion...
You know how those twitter accounts were like...
These are all just my opinion.
I'm not associated with any company or like my...
This is only my opinion.
But like...
I think if you like hit your head again...
We can un-concuss your concussion.
Wait, this way.
I have to go this way, right?
What other way do we go?
In my opinion, this is a magic word.
I fucking know, god.
I'm literally doing it right now, god.
Where else am I?
Oh, it's this way.
Okay.
God, I'm literally doing a thing.
God.
Wait, where the fuck am I?
What is this?
I barely see it.
Okay, here we go.
Up we go.
Up we go!
Where do I jump after this?
Like here?
Like where do I jump?
God is back seating me.
God is like...
Where do I go?
Oh...
Okay.
In my opinion, sir!
If you keep hitting yourself against the wall, we'll fix the head concussion!
But this is just my opinion!
You know, if I was wrong, it was you're the one that followed the opinion instead of getting actual, official medical advice!
That's your fault.
And watch where the tower falls?
Okay.
Come on, knock it down!
Hey, this way?
Where is that man falling?
Where am I?
Oh...
Ow!
Get up, please!
Get up!
Where did I come from?
Here?
Do I go up?
I must go up, right?
Oh shit!
Thank you for the taxi ride, I guess.
Sir, please!
Give me a sec.
Alright.
Up I go!
Where do I go from here then?
Like here?
Where else would I go?
Here?
Just down here?
Come on!
Right here!
Is the flower like my yellow spray?
Is that supposed to represent the yellow spray?
Oh, it is!
Oh my god!
The red flower is the new yellow paint!
I brought down the roof!
Oh my god!
Finally!
Where am I?
Finally, but also where am I?
How do I jump on his back though?
I don't know.
I'm gonna do something.
I see it.
Do you see it?
Circle emoji.
Did you see that?
There we go.
Alright, it's time to fucking fix your back, sir!
Just like how I fix your wife's back who's totally still alive!
It's almost the same!
Yes, she left you!
She's not dead or anything.
She definitely just left you!
That's it.
Oh, nice.
That nice.
Not nice right now.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Bro!
Calm the fuck down!
Your wife's like, oh my...
What?
I'm up here now.
Okay.
Don't worry, I can make this jump, right?
Yes, nice.
Oh, thank god.
Thank fucking god.
Okay, now I can poke.
Now I can like, fix his back.
There we go.
Let that juice out.
There.
Your wife loves it when I do this too.
You're totally alive.
Very much alive, wife.
Look, it's not my fault she left you!
Alright?
With like, no letter or anything too.
That's so fucking weird.
That's so weird, man.
That she like, left you with no letter or anything.
She just disappeared.
Like, where else would she go?
And then you could never find out...
And she never called back or anything.
She even like, left all her belongings too at the house.
It's like she never cared.
Alright.
Not even like, gave you like, any messages.
Not even with a text or anything.
You're very much a live wife.
Oh my god.
Please!
Let me fix your back!
I'm getting sad.
Why?
She's alive!
She's very much alive!
She just left with like, no other messages or anything.
Like, all her belongings were still in the house too.
It's so fucking weird.
But like, there's no foul play.
She needs to ram into something.
Please ram into something right now.
Okay, fuck this.
There you go.
Little by little.
I will force myself to puncture your back for health reasons!
It's so healthy!
Take your sins!
Okay, nice.
He just stuck there.
Did I glitch?
Did I glitch him?
Like, why is he not moving?
He's not moving at all!
Combo time!
Oh my god.
I'm gonna combo this person.
It's like when I put him in the corner in a fighting game.
I think I fucked him.
There you go.
Pro gamer.
He's taking the treatment so well.
Oh my god, he's so relaxed that he just lied back.
He's back in his back.
He fell asleep.
Never punish.
Let's go.
Woooo!
I'm here!
That's how you do it, Infinite!
We're doing it.
We're scheming so hard.
Is that my girlfriend?
My very much alive girlfriend?
Not like the guy's very much alive wife?
Oh my god, so many happy customers.
Guys, I think I'm doing it.
Look at all these happy customers right there.
There's actually a spot on most, if not all, Colossi that you can grab and will never be shaken from.
Speedrunner Tech.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's gay.
I appreciate it.
There's two more?
The next foe is...
That has fallen into the valley.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I sit there and shake my head 48 times in a row too if you told me my wife was gone.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yes, you're very much alive wife who left like no other evidence that she left you other than that she's gone.
It's so crazy that she even left all her belongings and her cash too.
And like even the car.
But like she's very much alive.
There you go.
The very alive wife.
Let's see.
Where do we go?
Oh yeah, we got to save to pray.
Pray to save.
Is this NTR or murder?
You'll never know.
That's a good question.
Find out next time.
On the next episode of Doki Bird.
Alright, we got to save to pray.
Of course it's not murder.
She's very much alive.
This way.
Alright.
This is like literally this entire like this play through has been 80% trying to figure out where the fuck I am.
I swear.
We spend less time.
Other than that fucking terrible bird client.
Other than that client.
The air sack client.
All the fucking colossi murder.
Like sorry, colossi patient.
Colossi clients have been pretty easy to deal with.
Like my job has been pretty easy.
What was that now?
Patients.
Clients.
My very much alive clients.
Okay, this way.
I'll go this way.
No, no, no.
You guys must have like had a...
All of you guys must have had like a small stroke right there.
What murder?
I would never.
Go Arlo, go.
I meant like a murder of crows.
A group of crows, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know, murder as in like a group, you know?
Like, you know, when they say a group of crows and I say a murder of crows.
It's like on the other side.
How do I get there?
How the fuck do I get there?
Oh God, how do I...
Where the fuck is that area?
Have I been to that shrine?
No, I haven't.
Oh wait, that's... I've been to this shrine.
Alright, let's grab this shrine first.
Save the prey.
Woo!
There you go.
Yay!
We did it!
Okay, where the fuck is the salamander?
This might be our last salamander.
Oh, there he is.
God, he's all the way up there again.
God damn it, get down from here.
You're not a fucking bird.
Oh wait, nope.
Nice.
Oh shit, he's like all the way up here.
No!
Don't know how to climb up there!
No.
No, you're not gonna have that privilege.
Where did he go?
God damn it.
God damn it, that's right.
The fucking vibration.
No.
No!
Where'd he go?
Where did he go?
Where the fuck did he fucking walk to?
I hear him.
Where is he?
He's on the ground?
They can do that?
That's fucking right.
That's fucking right, my man.
No.
There you go.
I got it.
I got it, I'm gonna double kill you.
Nice.
Alright.
We did it.
Yeah, they walk on the ground now?
I was like, what the fuck?
You can be on the ground?
Alright.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
Oh my gosh.
It was so difficult.
Where is this last one?
It's like right here.
We go across this bridge?
Right?
I can't tell.
Guys, do we go across this bridge, chat?
Is it this bridge?
Okay.
I just wanna be sure.
Yep?
No.
Okay.
Who the fuck said that?
Wes.
Okay.
Two people said no.
More said yes.
Wes, I'm gonna remember your name if you were wrong.
Do what you want.
Oh, this is the forest!
Wait.
This is the forest.
I don't think we go here.
Wait.
I don't think this is it.
Yeah, this is not the bridge.
We got...
Okay.
Wes might have been right.
Everybody else was wrong.
No, we do not.
Okay.
I remember like the other area led us to nowhere.
It's not this bridge.
Oh my God.
In the end, Wes was right.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe Wes was right all along.
He's lying.
I'm sorry.
Don't listen to him.
He's lying.
Okay.
This way.
All right.
Here we go.
This has to be the right way.
Yeah.
It has to be here.
Where else could it be?
He's lying.
I definitely have the guide open.
Okay.
All right.
Into the desert we go.
Okay.
I can't believe it.
It's like somewhere to our right.
Father of the sand.
Okay.
Who the fuck said yes before too?
I need to remember that guy's name instead.
God damn it.
I remembered the wrong person's name.
I always need to remember the people that are wrong so I can gloat.
Behind the castle.
There's a castle?
I wonder if I can go right from here.
It has to be, right?
Where else would it be?
I don't know.
There's like a passage here.
Oh, there it is!
Is that a castle?
Oh, my God!
That's a castle!
There is a castle!
I'm not the only person here.
A human has to make that castle.
Oh, my God.
There's a shrine here, too.
I get to eat another salamander.
All right.
Pray to save!
Where the fuck is the little bitch?
Oh, no!
Oh, there he is!
Okay.
The vibration is gonna knock him off.
God damn it, Arlo!
Alright, there you go.
Nice.
Yummy!
Alright, he gets to live.
For my infinite food glitch.
You can't save all of them, Arlo.
I'll eventually eat all the salamanders.
Alright.
Here we go.
This way.
To the castle we go!
He gets to live.
That salamander needs to thank Arlo for saving him.
I was just about to eat him too.
This is like this way, right?
That way to go in?
This way?
What other way to get in is there?
Just like this way?
Where is the castle?
Castle door opening.
Oh, here!
Found it!
I found it!
Wheeee!
Okay, there's a hole right here.
That means...
The hole is the goal.
Okay, how the fuck?
How?
Oh, the wrong entrance!
There's another entrance?
There's a slope here.
There's a front entrance?
Wait, what?
You mean there's more than one hole?
Guess we're gonna find out.
Wrong hole, apparently.
Oh my god, there is!
What the fuck?
Guys!
Did you guys know?
God gave us more than one hole?
Oh, I see.
Hahaha!
Hey, here we go.
I found it.
Yeah!
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do Ba-ba-dum-pa-pa-pa-pa Ba-ba-dum-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa I love that song.
I miss that group.
I love the songs they make.
My friend Steve.
Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da Steve.
Hahaha!
Wow!
We did it!
What the fuck?
Oh, it's this way.
Guys, why the fuck are there random holes?
It's baiting me so hard.
Oh, you don't know that song?
And my friend Steve.
Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da-da Steve.
Wait.
This is actually one of my favorite songs.
It's so funny.
Hahaha!
My friend Steve.
I can't believe it!
Me, you, and Steve!
Hahaha!
It's Garfunkel and Oates.
One...
They also have like a lot of other really good videos.
A lot of other really good songs too.
Here.
Hahaha!
It's 15 years ago!
Holy fuck!
Bro.
It was a good song.
Hahaha!
Alright.
No, I'm not listening to this song on my stream.
I have enough fucking copyright strikes, guys.
Hahaha!
Music people have taken enough of my money.
Up we go.
Can you not run up C's, Mr. Protagonist?
Bro!
What the fuck is he?
He's a giant, right?
Then where is he being a giant at?
Where is he?
Hello?
Giant?
Sir?
Steve, ba-da-da-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Hey!
Where is he?
Giant, sir!
Giant!
Where are you?
If you're such a giant, why can't I see you?
Hmm.
Oh!
There, I see you now.
Hahaha!
Whoa!
Hey!
You know what?
They were right about you.
You were pretty big.
Whoa!
King Kong.
Bro, I didn't mean it when I said I couldn't find you and that you might be short.
It was just a hee-hee funny joke!
Fuck you, Ox-I.
God, what do I do?
Hahaha!
God!
God, help me!
Oh!
Shit!
I don't think he liked it.
I don't think he liked that.
God, what do I do?
God!
Oh my god, can I climb anything?
Can I... Can I climb anything around here?
God, please.
God.
God, it's time.
Goal.
Survive.
Oh no.
King Kong's gonna fucking grab me, man.
Okay, I'm running.
I'm running.
There has to be a thing to climb.
This has to be climbable.
Nope.
Okay.
This has to... Nope.
Yes.
There has to be something out there that's climbable.
Climb him?
Where?
Oh god.
This is climbable?
This has to be climbable.
Climbable, please!
Where are the climbing parts?
I used to be able to climb everything!
Oh no.
Panels!
God, please!
I'm struggling, God!
God, show me the way.
Okay, his head is his heart.
Okay.
Oh my god.
There's panels?
Ah!
Is this a panel?
Are
these panels?
There's so many squares around.
There's...
There's so many squares.
Find a place.
I'm trying!
I can't climb!
Oh my god.
This is climbable.
Guys!
I'm figuring out the climb!
And then I jump here!
And then...
Alright.
And then what do I do?
And then... Okay, no.
No, okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna make you stop here.
This is apparently...
This is apparently a panel.
I think.
Yeah, I don't know about this one either.
Wait, he's walking a ramp right away.
Am I not like...
Guys, I'm important.
Sir?
I'm important too!
Sir, you're like...
Please sir!
Oh my god, I did one damage guys.
I did it.
Guys, I think the queue was happening.
Okay.
Don't put the queue like that.
You look a little mosquito.
Okay.
Is he gonna stomp on this?
Stomp, stomp, stomp.
Stomp?
One damage.
Let's fucking go.
What is he looking at?
Boop!
What's he gonna do?
Hello?
What is he even gonna do?
Nothing!
He's stuck!
Look at him!
Look at that little coward!
He's fucking stuck like a baby!
Am I doing something?
Do anything!
Woo!
Oh my god, I did it!
Oh my god, I'm so fucking smart!
I fucking did it!
He stepped on the panel.
I pulled his own.
Okay, now I'm up here.
Now I'm up here.
What do I do now?
Is he gonna...
Is he gonna duck down?
He made me a little ladder.
Maybe he's a good guy after all.
Wait, wait!
Do you see that?
Do you see that on his arm?
It's like a little pimple that I'm gonna poke!
That I'm missing every shot!
Hahaha!
Bro, it's your weak spot!
Okay.
No!
Don't leave me!
I'm a threat!
Sir!
Okay.
Come on!
I'm mean!
I'm a scary mean person!
Come on!
I need to turn around.
No!
Bro, give me your arm!
Give me your arm!
Bro!
Look at me!
I'm threatening!
Look at my hand!
Look at my bow!
Come on!
Turn around!
Turn around.
Stop moving!
He's ghosting me.
He says I'm not scary enough for him.
That's fucked up.
I built up a clientele that deserves to be noticed, sir.
Now turn around.
Is he gonna do a growl at me?
What's he doing?
Is he trying to have a conversation with me?
Hahaha!
Oh shit!
Okay.
Oh my god, he's having a tamper tantrum right now.
Bro, how the fuck is this knocking me around?
Oh shit!
Okay.
He's pro-situated.
Bro, I'm trying to help!
I'm gonna shoot you in the ass if you don't let me help you.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
He's like ignoring me.
Bro, am I not important?
Guys.
Am I...
Am I not important?
No way.
No.
There's no way I'm relevant, right?
No way.
I have to be relevant, right?
No!
Not that way!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
You were turning around!
Go up higher?
I can climb up higher?
Wait.
I can?
Where?
Oh my god.
Guys.
No.
How?
I... this?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
That's an accident!
No!
No, that's an accident!
Please!
No, but steady.
That's an accident!
Turn your fucking head!
Please, for the love of God, just let me shoot you in the arm.
Let me shoot you on the fucking arm!
Please!
Bro, please, for the love of God.
Just turn around.
I need your other arm.
Your other arm has the weak point.
There's no weak point here.
There's literally no weak point!
Stop moving.
Okay.
I'm trying.
I'm trying so hard.
I swear.
Come on.
Okay, that's right.
That's me.
Now, give me your arm.
Give me your arm.
Give me your little poke.
Yes.
I move that.
Yep.
I move that arm.
Come on.
You know you want to.
Look, I did damage.
Ow!
But look at the damage I did, though.
But look at that damage I did.
Please, just show me your other...
Oh my God.
Show me your other arm!
That's all I want!
Bro, I fucking swear.
I fucking swear.
Just try and hit something.
Anything!
Oh my God!
Finally!
Oh, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
But he fucking finally did it.
Holy shit!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh, now you...
Okay, now you fucking...
Okay.
We did it, guys.
It took him 20 years, but we fucking did it.
I don't know why it took him that long.
This had to be the longest strike of my life.
I watched him dance longer than this.
Like...
I spent more of the time watching him fucking dance.
Where does he strike here?
Did you make him strike here?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Here?
Okay, maybe here.
Oh my God, there's...
He
wants to know...
I will be the one to...
What did I do, dummy?
What did I do?
I hit it.
What now?
Okay, now he just has his arm.
What if I just do it again?
Oh.
Okay, nevermind.
What now?
Is he gonna pick it back up?
Nice, I fixed his arm.
I gave him a shot.
Shot, shot, shot, shot, shot, shot.
Can he...
Is he gonna slam this?
Go to the...
What is this?
There's a bridge.
Oh, there's a bridge.
There's stairs.
Guys, there's fucking stairs.
Oh my God.
There's stairs, guys.
I did it.
I found the stairs.
Can't believe we wouldn't slam down for so long.
Wait, maybe that's...
I'll need a sword here.
Here we go.
Fight me.
Fight me right here.
Now I'm taller than you.
That means I'm more important!
That's fucking right!
Get a little closer.
Come on.
Try to jump on him.
What's he gonna do?
Slap?
He's gonna slam it.
He actually is gonna slam it!
Guys,
it was crazy.
He actually did the thing.
Holy fuck damn.
Oh my god.
He actually slammed it.
Who would've thought?
That's
fucking crazy, man.
He actually did it.
Alright.
I need him to stomp on here.
Who's taller now?
Guys, I need him to stomp on this.
On me.
Right here.
That's me.
It's me, sir.
Yes.
It's me.
Please.
I wanna be tall just like you.
And not blow up.
Please.
Stomp on this.
Yes.
Wooo!
Ow.
That's alright.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you for the little booster seat.
And then... climb up.
Climb up.
Yes!
Oh fuck.
How did I miss?
There was like only one way to jump.
And I still missed.
Oh my god.
This is so hard to see.
From this angle.
Alright.
Where is it?
Here?
Oh there it is.
There's the stairs.
Boop.
Stair time.
Yeeeah!
Don't worry.
We got this.
Alright.
I am here.
Ready for our appointment for real this time.
He was a little feisty.
But we did it.
We convinced him.
I guess I just jump on him from here.
That's right.
Get over here.
We are not behind schedule.
Because you wouldn't fucking swing.
The other side?
Why the other side?
I can make it from here.
Watch.
Oh!
Okay.
I actually did not think it would work.
But...
First try.
I can punch your time.
Let's let it go.
Who said other side?
This is a doki way.
Never doubted.
Where are my believers?
Where are my believers in chat?
That's fucking right.
It was for you guys.
Nice speed.
But fucking other side.
I don't need other sides.
I just need one side.
All according to plan.
Oh wait.
It's gone now.
What the fuck?
Wait.
What?
Excuse me?
What do you mean it's gone?
Wow!
Shit!
Excuse me?
Where is your...
Where are your other spots?
There's other spots?
There's other spots that you need help on?
Oh!
I see it!
It's right there!
Right?
Is it...
Is it right over there?
Oh no.
I'm gonna recharge real fast.
I'm gonna stay up here and recharge.
We'll be fine.
He's just being a little feisty right now.
Wait.
No.
That's the spot to drop the sword.
Did you see it?
Guys.
What the fuck?
He had other spots?
No.
I know what I'm doing.
I'm a professional.
I get paid for this.
I don't totally know where it is.
AHHHHHHHHH!
No.
Where the fuck is...
I mean I know where it is guys.
I definitely know.
Oh it's his head.
What the fuck?
Can I like climb and hold my head?
Get over here.
What the fuck?
Where?
How the fuck do I just hit the head?
Did I shoot him?
What if I just keep shooting the head?
Okay.
Maybe it's here?
Maybe he like goes up here.
Okay.
And then I just like...
Just hold his hand.
Come on.
Right here.
Step on this.
Step on it.
Oh god.
I need to watch this.
Okay.
No.
Not yet.
Don't watch it.
Am I okay?
I'm okay.
Watch this guys.
I'm gonna hold... watch this.
He's gonna get close to me.
And then I'm gonna hold the head.
Oh my god.
It's right in the head.
How the fuck?
Are there... Is there fur on the head?
I can't tell.
I can't tell if the...
The head has fur.
That I can like grip on.
Come on.
Stab it.
Oh my god.
Come on.
Please.
This is for your own medical concern right here.
Alright.
Is he gonna slam?
Are you gonna slam now?
What are you doing?
What the fuck are you doing?
Just slam.
What are you doing?
Are you dancing?
Here?
He's gonna slam.
He's gonna do it.
Come on.
Come on!
Swing your hand!
Oh it's flexing.
Why are you shy?
Bro!
Just move!
What are you doing, bro?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna fucking shoot you.
Just slam!
Don't be a little bitch.
Oh my god.
Are you gonna...
Bro, he's just standing there menacingly.
He's just wiggling.
There's nothing I can do.
He's just keep wiggling.
There you go.
I'll shoot you in the hand if you don't get over here right now.
Oh my god.
Why the fuck did I like make him lose his axe?
If I didn't make him lose his axe, this would have been so easy.
I just had to shoot his arm.
I just had to do that.
Come on.
Do it.
Swing this.
You know you want to.
This is me.
Right here.
Come on.
I'm like so out in the open.
So defenseless.
Just do something.
Anything.
Oh my god.
You're pissing me off.
I'm going to give you hidden fees as well.
You're going to have hidden fees as well, man.
Okay, I'm going to go up the level on this side then.
At least stand on this panel.
It's hidden fees time.
Come on.
Stand on it.
Nice.
Wait, wrong panel.
I can work with that.
Actually.
Yeah, I can work with it.
Alright, this way.
Alright, up another floor.
Can't see what's going on on my camera.
But I think I'm okay.
Alright, here we go.
Now it's time.
It's time to do this again.
Don't worry.
We don't need the other side.
I can't believe it.
Thank you for this.
Thank you.
He has performance anxiety.
Here we go again.
Alright.
This is it.
Right here we go.
I knew it would always work.
I knew it.
I think it's this side, right?
Which arm is it?
Guys, give me a sec.
I need to remember which arm it is.
Guys, is it the left arm?
Or the right arm?
Chat.
Wait, can I actually grab the arm?
Is it the right?
It's the right arm.
Yeah?
The sword arm.
No!
No,
please.
Let's go!
Oh shit, here we go again.
Here we go again.
Oh, bait and hand swing?
Oh, is that it?
I go in the middle and then I bait?
Okay, here we go.
I got this.
Swing that arm.
Swing it.
Swing that...
No, no, no, not the feet!
Swing that arm.
Come on, do it.
Swing that fucking arm.
Swing it.
Please just...
Just keep swinging.
You know you want to.
Oh my god, he's swinging the arm.
Oh my god, he's doing it!
No!
It's okay, I figured it out.
Guys!
Let me hold the arm!
Oh my god, please.
Please, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, don't get closer.
Jesus Christ.
That window is like...
The window to like...
I got knocked a leg again.
No, don't get closer.
Please, for the love of god.
What if I hold this?
No!
Please!
This is a medical emergency!
What if you have cancer on the hand?
Let me see!
Not medical profession, but professional.
Just in case.
Not medical professional, but like...
I'm just trying to like help.
Please.
Please!
Your hand glowing is not a good sense!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No!
Please!
Fuck yeah!
Please.
Please, please.
Just let me stick my knife in the hand.
That's all I ask.
That's all I ask!
I just wanna stick my...
knife into your hand.
No!
Please!
It's just one stab!
Oh my god!
It's like...
Literally one stab!
Okay.
He's baiting me.
He's fucking baiting me.
Bro!
You fuck!
He's actually baiting me so hard right now.
He's trolling me.
He's trolling me right now.
He actually is.
Give me your arm!
Give me your fucking arm!
Oh!
Wait!
You can walk past that?
He walked over it...
I can't believe it.
I'm so sad.
I've been stuck in this room.
I can never get him to let me check his hand.
He won't let me check his hand.
I don't understand.
I'm so sad.
Please.
All I ask...
Just let me...
Let me grab the hand.
Please.
It'll be so fast.
It's just a little pause.
Not the feet.
Not the feet!
I meant the hand!
Get that shit away from me!
Get away!
Be gone!
Oh my god.
Not the other foot.
Not the other foot!
I didn't mean give me the other one.
Sir, please.
Am I far enough?
I should be far enough.
Oh my god.
Sir, I told you.
Get that shit away from me!
It's not the feet.
It's the hand!
Alright.
This time.
This is the longest fight we've ever had just because he wouldn't give me the hand.
I swear to god.
Oh my god.
Please.
Yes!
He actually held his air!
Oh my god!
I'm holding the hand!
Don't worry!
It's just a benign pimple!
It's just benign!
I'm pumping really quick with my sharp sword!
I'm burning so there's no bacteria on the sword!
Oh my god.
Bro.
This was the worst customer I've ever had.
I cured him.
Done.
Oh my god.
I'm blacklisting this customer.
Holy shit.
Good job holding his hand!
Wes, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
This was worse than the bird who was trying to find the girlfriend.
We literally needed to just hold his hand.
And this fucker was too shy.
He was too scared.
Another happy customer.
Never return.
I'm closing my doors for this customer.
Yay!
Two people in the black.
I was like, this is one of the easiest ones.
And I swear to fucking god.
I'm holding.
I swear my god was bugged out or some shit.
There's no fucking way.
He had to be bugged out.
Because it took me so long.
Oh, it's nearly over!
I'm about to complete the ritual to have my girlfriend back!
Guys!
I'm gonna make it!
He stands in the way.
What is that?
You are a quick one.
I am not a quick one.
Who the fuck is that?
Alright, time to pray.
Oh, Arlo.
Oh my god, Arlo.
That guy fucking sucked.
I hope he never calls back and asks me to fix his problems again.
Bro.
Oh my god, this guy is forever banned.
Banned from ever.
I'm gonna fucking block his number.
He's never... I don't care how much he pays, man.
That guy fucking sucked.
That guy fucking was terrible, man.
He wouldn't fucking... He kept giving me his feet.
I was like, bro.
I was like, sir?
Sir?
I'm not a feet doctor, sir.
Sir, I need the hand, not the feet.
It was terrible.
He wouldn't fucking stop.
Even if he paid a billion.
You see that, right?
It was like...
Messages that like...
People who do like OnlyFans.
And then like they get like...
They like post like...
The types of tweets and DMs...
The type of DMs they get in private messages.
They'll be like, I'll give you like...
I'll give you one million dollars if you give me an exclusive picture.
Exclusive picture of feet.
There's like...
I've seen like Twitter message...
Like Twitter post back then.
Of like girls.
Like girl...
Like they don't even do any of those like OnlyFans stuff.
They just like...
They just post on like Twitter like pictures of themselves.
And they will get like private DMs and stuff.
And being like, ma'am.
I know like you don't offer any of these.
But like what if like I give you like a hundred thousand dollars for just one picture, ma'am.
Just one...
One picture.
I'm like, what?
What the fuck?
And I was like, holy shit.
And they're just like, guys, you know, a million's a million.
Like to the left.
Not here.
Like just regular...
Regular like...
Not just women.
But like regular guys who are just...
Regular like...
Like women and men who are just like good looking.
They get like random DMs and stuff like that.
And I'm like, whoa.
Oh, my God.
Where did they get these?
Saudi prince.
True.
Yeah.
It's real oiler.
Alright.
Wrong.
Wrong entrance.
Where do I go?
There's nowhere here.
Should I go to the right?
I mean for a million.
Do I go to the right or the left?
Where is...
I want 100k.
Is it right side?
Check the map.
Which way is self?
Self is down.
Self is down!
Okay, self is this way.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, you mean like...
Is it that one to the right?
Is it this one?
Is it...
That entrance over there to the far right?
Wait, how do I zoom in?
Is it like here?
Wait...
Like over here.
You see where I'm... Okay, you guys might not know where I'm looking at, but...
That little hole?
Right there?
That little hole over there?
Right here?
Like right here?
I don't know if you guys can see it.
This hole.
This has to be the hole, right?
I'ma look at the right one.
Alright, right here.
Alright.
Arlo, where the fuck are you going?
Okay, just follow this.
Don't worry.
I have autopilot on for Arlo.
Thank God for autopilot, Arlo.
All the way down.
So like all the way down there?
At the very edge of the map?
Uhhh...
I guess I'll go this way.
Actually...
Does it matter which way I go?
I'll go this way actually.
Yeah.
Okay.
All the way down, Arlo.
This is gonna be a long ride.
We're at the finish line, Arlo.
You know, I can't wait after I finish this game to play Hello Kitty Adventure.
One of the best games ever made.
I never played it before, but I expected to be one of the best.
Alright, let me just go straight down.
Yeah!
Hell yeah!
Bring on Hello Kitty!
Hello Kitty!
The critically acclaimed sequel.
Sequel of what?
Like...
There's a...
There's a first one?
But I've never heard of it.
Okay, it has to be the cloud all the way down here.
Use the sword?
I mean, I don't need to know...
Use the sword if I know it's like down...
There's no way...
Go back up!
Okay, I need to figure out how to get down.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I need...
Holy...
Thank God, the edge.
My life.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, that was...
That was a little risky.
Guys, that was just...
Just a little risky!
Just a little bit!
Whoa, I stopped myself before anybody got hurt.
Whoa.
That was...
That was a little wild of me to do.
It's a...
Just a little wild.
Oh, now you jump off cliffs, Arlo.
Okay.
Like this way.
It has to be like in between those two cliffs, right?
It has to be.
Here we go.
Where else could it be?
Come on, Arlo.
You can do it.
Come on.
Arlo, come on.
Don't be a little pussy!
Come on.
Eventually, Arlo will drop down with me, right?
Arlo!
Hello, Arlo.
Come on.
Arlo, come on!
You're gonna teleport right behind me anytime now.
Anytime.
Arlo, are you teleporting?
Arlo?
Arlo, you're gonna teleport, right?
Arlo.
Oh, he's going the long way.
Oh, my god.
I'm glad he's smart.
He actually went the long way.
No, he doesn't quit!
Look, see?
Look at him!
What a good horse!
Oh my god!
I made it!
I hit the jump!
I'm a professional horse driver.
Alright, this way.
This way, here I go!
Yay!
It has to be this.
Okay, and then I raise my sword.
And then I hit it.
Yeah!
I did it!
Yippee!
Arlo, get over here.
I need to keep my five stars, Arlo.
Okay, okay, no, no, no.
I'm right here, Arlo.
No, no, no.
Right here.
What the fuck?
Is it... Do I go up here?
Wait, where do I go?
Where the fuck is the...
Here?
Arlo?
Right here?
Oh!
Sorry.
Yeah!
Use Arlo?
I don't need to use Arlo.
Is it here?
Oh no, where's the sun?
Where did the sun go?
Wait, I do need Arlo?
Arlo, apparently I need you.
Wait, is that a shrine?
Oh shit!
Okay, guys, give me a sec.
I need to go to the shrine.
Guys, I need to go to the shrine.
Arlo can jump across?
He can?
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
We need to pray first.
Give me a sec.
Pray!
Pray?
Pray.
Oh my god, now you don't believe in God anymore?
Pray!
Okay.
This is it.
We need to find the lizard.
I hear him, but like, where is...
Oh, there he is.
He's like hiding up here.
I got the tail!
Did you guys see that?
I specifically hit the tail!
Okay, now I need to figure out how to climb this.
Oh my god.
There we go.
I don't like how there's no sun.
Doesn't make me... fuck.
Okay.
I don't like that.
No, are you fucking kidding me?
Alright.
Jump.
Here we go.
Boop.
Yay!
Alright.
I know, please.
Apparently I need you.
Apparently they said I need you.
Oh god.
No.
I'm gonna drive this horse.
Please.
Barlow, please.
There we go.
Nice.
Okay, and then...
Up we go.
Oh.
Here we go.
And then...
This is where we do it.
Make the jump, Barlow.
I believe.
It's time.
Can you make this jump?
We need hands!
No!
It's okay.
Guys, Arlo can swim.
Right, guys?
Guys.
Guys, Arlo can...
Wait, guys.
Let me look at my screen.
No, Arlo!
Guys, I have empathy.
I swear to god.
We all know horses can swim!
They're fine!
They can swim!
We all know they can swim, guys!
Horses can swim!
If I can swim, so can Arlo!
Why?
Guys.
If I can swim, so can Arlo, guys.
We all know this.
We all know this, guys.
Like, we all know this.
Am I going the right way?
I can never tell.
I assume it's this way.
I assume.
I'm not gonna sugarcoat it.
He don't...
What do you mean?
I didn't wanna bring Arlo!
I wasn't gonna bring him along!
You guys forced me.
I was gonna protect Arlo.
I wanted to protect him!
D-Dragon.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Guys, that's fucked up, guys.
You guys did that.
I was gonna bring him along.
I wasn't gonna bring him along.
No.
You killed Arlo.
Not me.
It's okay.
Horses don't take fall...
Yeah!
Horses don't take fall damage.
Right, Frozen?
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Guys, horses don't take fall damage, guys.
That's what Minecraft taught me.
Wait, actually... No, wait.
Horses can die from fall damage.
Guys, this isn't like...
This is like Arlo Minecraft.
Guys.
It's okay.
He had water.
No!
They don't take fall damage if there's water!
They don't take like...
They don't take fall damage!
If there's water!
Chat.
Wait, I wasn't supposed to... This is just an easter egg.
I guess I'll grab the easter egg.
Since I'm here.
I guess I'll just grab this.
I gotta recharge.
Where do I go then?
Huh?
I wasn't even supposed to be here.
No!
I'm okay.
I ate so much fruit.
I'm gonna see to the right.
Guys, do you guys know if you hold it, you jump further away?
You jump further away?
I wonder how long have people been yelling at me to hold my axe.
Guys!
Did you guys... I just found out guys!
Oh my god!
I just found out that if you hold down, you can jump further.
Shit.
Makes me wonder how long people...
Uh...
How long people have yelled at me.
Really?
Makes you wonder?
Where do I go though?
Was it not this way?
Oh wait.
I don't know which way to go.
I assume like...
Maybe like this way.
I'll go this way.
I have no idea where to go.
I'm a little lost.
Oh shit!
Did I go the wrong way?
Was it this way this entire time?
Guys, I think I went the wrong way.
Oh my god.
Guys.
There's a possibility that I went the wrong way this entire time.
Weeeeee!
This way.
Oh, this way.
Weeeeee!
Wait, we lost our guide.
I don't know what to do now.
We lost our horse guide.
What do I do when we don't have a guide?
Is this a colossi?
Am I climbing a colossi right now?
There's no way, right?
No.
I don't think so.
This can't be, right?
Oh no, it looks fucking weird.
I feel like I'm climbing a colossi.
Like, why are there grasses growing around?
Feels like...
This feels like a colossi.
Because it's built so weird too.
Alright.
Inside I go.
Inside up I go.
Up.
Up up.
Alright.
Woah!
Where do I go from here?
What?
Okay.
Look at this.
Jump up?
Oh, I do!
Oh my god.
Guys.
I feel like...
Oh my god!
Yeah, I was not climbing.
What the fuck?
He's like Samurai Jack.
Yeah, I was not climbing.
I was not climbing colossi.
Bro, how do you have screens on when...
when it's raining?
More like Samurai Jack.
Wait.
He's like...
pointing at me.
Me?
Oh, he was not pointing at me!
Guys, he was not...
I'm okay.
Guys, he was absolutely...
What the fuck?
How?
I'm gonna heal up.
I'm gonna heal up, guys.
I'm not okay.
I'm not okay!
Oh my god.
How do I get closer?
How the fuck do I get closer?
I'm healing so slow, too.
Okay.
What?
That's bullshit!
I... He hit me in the air!
I...
He hit me in the air!
Holy shit!
That guy fucking hit me in the air!
That's so fucked up!
Not the heal!
I have to help!
He actually hit me in the air!
Alright, guys.
A little Super Chat reading time because...
I need to...
regen my HP apparently.
Thunder and Sandy is doing the same thing over and over again.
Expecting different results.
Thank you for this Super Chat.
Thank you.
We're gonna have to...
sit down and do some Super Chat readings.
Because...
He fucked me up real good, you guys.
Hiro, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Where is Arlo?
When I need him!
Cucumber, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Where is he?
Where is Arlo?
Arlo!
Where are you?
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Arlo would have been able to...
outrun this man.
He would have been able to outrun...
his fire blast.
Okay.
Where do I go from here?
Oh, shit!
This is like...
bullshit.
Why does he do like...
200,000 damage?
Oh my god.
How does he do so much damage now?
What?
Where do I go?
I'm trying...
I'm trying to find cover.
Bro.
Okay, guys.
Back to...
back to Super Chat reading.
Say thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Frozen, thank you for the Super Chat.
Just saying, Arlo would have dodged those blasts.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Guys, let's back to...
back to the...
being a floor bitch real fast.
Okay, here we go.
There's no way he gets me down here.
There's no way.
There we go.
We have cover.
Where do we go from here?
Okay, maybe like here?
Okay, and then...
Run!
Now where do I go?
There we go.
We made it.
Oh my god, we made it to the other hole.
We did it!
Alright, up we go.
I'm learning.
I'm learning the rolls.
They've taught me to roll.
Okay, and then here we go.
Where do we go from here to knockdown?
No, I have to go this way.
Okay.
Thought I could barely see where I'm at.
Okay, and then up we go.
There's no way he could see me.
I'm camouflaged.
The power of dodging.
This is my Dark Souls of the month.
Okay, I was gonna say it.
There's no fucking way I'm gonna die today.
I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
I'm in the hole.
I'm in the hole with a goal in mind.
Hell no.
Here I roll.
Here I go up.
Here I go.
And then climb.
And then where?
I'm getting closer guys.
Look.
I can see his skirt from up here.
Oh my god, please.
Please!
Why can't you get up?
Go right I think.
It must be right.
Where else would I have to go?
RUN!
Nice.
Okay.
RUN!
RUN?
Oh nice.
Alright.
Nice we did it.
I was so confused cause I saw stairs and I was like do I do something that I was taught to do again?
I was like, there's stairs.
Oh shit, I'm looking up.
Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha Guys.
I think I might get arrested.
Guys.
Oh fuck.
Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha
Where do we climb?
Here?
Oh here.
Okay we got it.
We got it.
Nice.
I think it's just parkour.
Is this all parkour?
It has to be.
Where am I?
What's going on?
Is the wind working against me?
That's a thing?
Can I grab onto this?
Shoot in the air.
Hahahaha Hahahaha Yo, yo, yo.
He's so funny.
I'm climbing up here.
Am I going up?
I can't tell.
I'm going to need to jump.
Hmmm.
Jump from here.
Oh my god.
This is going to take fucking forever.
Bro, he's so fucking tall!
This man is so tall!
It's going to take fucking forever to jump up!
What am I going to do from here?
Is that thing going to get closer?
There's no way I'm going to hit that jump.
So it has to be that over here, right?
No, there's no way.
It's not going to move closer.
It's going to go this way.
I don't think that's going to move any closer to me.
Okay.
Oops.
Okay, where's his heart?
Oh yeah, it's like way up.
Oh my god.
I'm getting closer.
I'm getting so close.
Here we go.
Arm time!
Only up!
Oh god.
Woo!
Up back up.
Oh!
There's a spot!
It's right here!
That's right!
Is
that it?
Did I do it?
Did I fix his back?
I fixed it!
Wait, do I grab the hand?
Oh
my god.
It's like fast track.
It's like fucking fast track right here.
Sorry,
that was the most primal scream I've had in a while.
My life flashed before me.
I swear.
I thought I had to do this all over again.
What a save.
Oh my god.
I had the most fun.
I had the most primal scream.
Oh my god.
That scared the shit out of me.
That actually scared the shit out of me.
Holy fuck.
Okay, we're not doing that again.
Am I?
Alright.
This way.
Here we go.
That's the jump.
Okay, we do it again.
We do it again.
Holy fuck.
That was so scary.
That was so primal.
You guys have no idea how fucking scary that was for me.
Oh my god.
Bro, I fucking hate this so much.
Not again.
I'm so scared.
Oh my god.
Not again.
Why is this so difficult?
Please don't keep...
It's so hard to grab the arm.
Oh my god.
This is sad.
It's just like it's the gorilla all over again.
It's the gorilla all over again, chat.
It's the fucking gorilla.
Gorilla curse.
I blame the gorilla curse, guys.
It's the curse of the gorilla.
The curse of the fucking gorilla.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Why can't I reach this?
I can't hear you.
Alright.
Hold on to his- oh wait, you mean he lifts his hand to his face?
Guys, I didn't know that!
I thought I had to climb with the arm!
Like the others- like the bird guy!
Okay.
I'm doing it again.
For the third time's a charm.
This time I got it.
Okay, I just have to climb.
I just gotta hold on.
I knew it.
Just climb.
Please.
Just fucking climb.
Just climb.
Nooo.
No, don't let go.
Don't let go, Jack.
We
gotta poke you again.
So I can have a better pull down.
For this.
No.
No, I s- Nooooo!
Please.
Just jump!
Oh my god!
Nice.
Not nice.
Wooo!
Not nice, guys!
Not nice, not nice, not nice, not nice.
Please tell me there's something to grab on here!
Oh, thank god!
Oh, thank god, oh thank god, thank god.
I think I fucked it up though.
Unless... No!
I'm gonna start off from the-
Alright, here we go again.
All of them are getting blacklisted.
Fuck all of these guys.
Alright.
What
do I jump do again?
Please.
Get on top of the pump!
Stab the head!
I did it!
Stab the
- BACKWARDS!
Guys, I think I went backwards... again.
Guys, I went backwards.
Shoot
for - But there's fire!
There's fire though!
I'm scared!
We need to recharge a little.
We gotta recharge a little.
Woah, woah, woah, woah!
Okay.
Oh no, please.
I'm so scared.
Just chill, just chill, just chill!
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
Did you see it?
I'm
scared.
I got scared.
I thought I fucked it up.
Oh my god, I thought I fucked it up.
Oh,
we're okay.
Guys.
I'm so scared.
Oh no.
Oh god.
I'm so scared.
Guys, I'm so scared.
The other shoulder?
Where do I- It's right here.
It's right here.
Oh my god, we've made it.
No!
Oh shit!
Holy fuck!
That
was so close.
That was so close.
Oh my god, that was...
Not cool.
That fucked it all up, guys.
Okay.
We made it.
After 20 years!
We made it!
Oh!
We
gotta get closer.
One last acupuncture!
Oh god.
Sir!
Sir, you need this inch for your-
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god.
Stop!
Just let me do my job!
Okay.
Jesus Christ, why is the safe so light?
Am I like not at the head?
I can't tell because I'm swinging so much!
Here we go.
I couldn't tell if I'm poking it correctly.
Zing!
That sounds like me.
Not gonna lie, that sounds just like me.
Look!
He keeps swinging his head!
Of course I was gonna miss eventually!
Oh my god, I'm getting a little scared now.
I feel like I'm gonna fall now.
Not gonna lie.
Charge it just a little bit.
Nice, okay.
Oh thank god, okay I didn't miss this time.
Sorry, I might have actually hit your brain, but don't worry, don't worry.
Here is a coupon for one free coin.
Free head massage?
Don't worry sir, don't worry.
They weren't the important parts in your brain, guys.
It wasn't like... it wasn't like the important parts in the brain, so do not worry.
Do not worry sir.
You'll be fine.
Okay.
I have no time.
Oh thank god.
Okay, I have one more stab.
One more stab.
Come on sir.
Sir!
Okay!
Oh god.
I saw myself stumble.
It would be a doki moment if I fell right now.
It would truly be the most doki moment.
No!
You fucking kidding me!
They warned me!
I mean like, one more stress point.
Boom.
We did it!
We hope you will enjoy the doki bird acupuncture experience.
Not the doki moment.
Oh my god.
All that stress toxin coming out right now.
Where am I?
Oh shit!
Hehehehe.
Nightmare Slain.
I did it!
I'm a hero!
Oh my god, they're coming to my turf.
Get out!
This is my clientele!
Why does he have a white horse?
How does he get to be so special?
What is he doing on my turf?
Here, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The rival Aki punch you.
What are you doing?
Bro, he has a mask too?
That's when you know he's like a professional.
Did you remember to pay your perfection protection?
I am the protection!
What do you mean?
This is my turf!
Oh my god, is she better now?
Is she healed?
Lord Imon?
He gets to be a lord?
Oh, that's when I killed the last colossus.
Yay, now it's so roomy now.
Look at all the space.
I'll get the taxi back home.
Is she better now?
I did it!
I healed my girlfriend!
Now it's Doki turns for being stabbed.
Noisy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What do you mean?
I'm the good guy, right?
That looks like a good guy right there.
Is he doing Yamcha pose?
Oh my god, I can fly now.
That's the Peter pose.
Oh yeah, you're right.
That's more like the Peter pose.
The family guy pose.
What are they doing to my girlfriend?
What are you doing?
Hands off.
That's right or I'll get very angry.
All my friends are here.
All my clients.
My five star review.
Bro, I look so...
Okay.
What have I done?
I got my girlfriend back.
Look, if it was forbidden, you should have made a sign.
I'm like a horned angel, right?
Angels have horns, right?
Oh.
My knee.
Bro, what?
Skyrim hasn't come out yet.
Oh my god, this was...
The last...
The last Colossus walked so Skyrim can run.
Acupuncture...
No, not the...
No way!
I mean, it's like hair salon, people.
Wait, am I going to die?
Oh
my god, my stress juice!
I was so fucking stressed.
I'm stressed.
The last acupuncture is just acupuncture.
Taster, I think you missed.
Bro, you know what?
I was pretty stressed out.
I was definitely pretty stressed out.
Yo, I finally got my own obsession.
At least talk to my girlfriend.
She looks live!
She has blood in her face now.
All the stress is coming out.
I was so fucking stressed, man.
Another happy client.
I
didn't have to work so hard.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I was just going to be a huge, massive, huge fan.
You're a big fan of the next episode.
Yeah.
That's right.
I'm gonna have to find...
I guess it's a good thing.
I'm not gonna give it a go at this point.
I'm gonna keep it consistently.
Just like I always say, this is just a month.
Well, in your book...
Thanks, man.
Yeah.
Can't beat a bad guy.
He's got...
Wait,
am I gonna kill him?
Oh my god!
I'm the good guy!
Let's go!
I'm good!
What the fuck do I do?
That's fucking right!
I'm the good guy!
Doki smash!
I can't see anything!
Where am I getting hit by?
Where are the people at?
You're so tiny!
Oh my god, where are they?
Oh, here you are.
Here you are.
I see you.
I got you in the corner.
Bam!
That's fucking right.
Doki smash!
For justice!
Bam!
How do I keep missing?
Can you guys walk a little further up so I can actually hit you guys?
Okay, I'm trying to figure out the perspective.
Okay.
Guys, I've realized...
I've realized that being Colossus is really difficult.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Dude, they're getting away!
God, how are you so slow?
God, how are you so slow?!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Bro, I can't believe.
The more you...
No wonder they were so stressed out.
Now I know how they feel.
What is he gonna do?
What is that?
He just throws the sword?
What?
Oh,
his mask!
It's handmade!
Oh, and it's still there.
That's good.
I
have so my girlfriend!
I can't believe the good guy is losing.
I couldn't even...
Don't grab onto it!
No!
Bro!
Can you grab the wall?
If I learn everything, I just need to grab...
Oh, fuck it.
Let's go.
Hold onto something!
I've accepted it.
I accepted it.
Just grab something.
My license for books.
I can't believe it!
How did they know this wasn't a real license?
How did they know?
How did... I can't believe the inspector came!
I did my job perfectly!
I watched the YouTube guides!
I can't believe it.
The inspector came.
Who called on me?
Who like ratted me out to the inspectors?
To the acupuncture inspectors?
They just left her?
I don't know.
After all that?
I guess because they thought she was dead.
She's alive!
Look at her!
Now she's less dead looking.
They'll be like, how the fuck did I get here?
She's like, what the fuck?
Where am I?
The power of acupuncture.
It works.
Even if my license wasn't real, my skills were.
She just walked away?
She doesn't even know where the fuck to go?
Oh my god, I can control the camera.
Arlo!
I knew it!
Minecraft was right!
I
knew horses can swim!
I fucking knew it!
Arlo!
Are you limping?
Oh no!
No!
Oh, Arlo stealing your girl!
Broken bot!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I fucking knew it!
Minecraft was right!
We did it!
Saved!
I knew I was the good guy all along!
Oh my god!
We fucking- Oh, these are all the dead that Colossa have killed.
Oh, they like become one with the nature.
Afterwards.
We did it chat!
Oh my god.
We fucking did it.
We beat the game.
Another game completed!
We did it!
Thank you for coming to the journey!
Of Shadow Colossi!
Colossus!
Wait, is there an after credit?
Alright, let me turn down the sound a little bit.
There's an after credit?
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
We'll wait until the after credit then.
Oh my god!
Good job!
I did it!
Thank you!
I won!
Poor Chester!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh my god.
What a journey.
Opening up my massage parlor, being the very best, and still having my license taken from me?
I can't believe it.
I was doing such a great job.
It's like those honorary degrees.
I should have gotten an honorary license for all the Colossus I've saved.
All the fucking stress I helped get rid of.
Someone had to call the inspector.
No fun.
Now Arlo and girl get to eat grass worms and lizard tails in this peaceful land.
They give us a super chat.
Uh, Cas, thank you.
Thank you.
I did such a good job too!
I got like five star Yelp reviews and everything.
I don't understand.
I don't...
How did... how did this happen?
That was really fun.
I don't know what series to do next week though.
I'm trying to think of like what my new series should be.
There's so many games I want to play.
So I don't know which one to start first.
Um... I might do... I don't know actually.
I don't know which game to do next because there's like so many I want to play.
There's so many games I've always wanted to play.
So it's always hard to figure out the next series.
Um, but I have like a backlog of... I wrote down a backlog of games that I wanted...
Oh my gosh, wait, it's still going?
Oh my god, they're breaking the bridges.
You can go on top of that bridge?
How come I could never?
What the fuck?
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You can't have your license taken away if you never had one to be going.
Oh, true.
True.
I have an honorary license.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
You could be on top of that this whole time?
I've always been under there.
Oh my god.
I don't know man.
Just... just try.
Just...
just try.
Man, I must not go on this anymore.
It's just me and my mother.
The only other thing that matters is that I'm alive.
That's the only other thing that matters.
Hope you'll let me know that you're alive.
I saved my girlfriend.
You saved my girlfriend?
Yeah.
What do you mean?
I mean this whole game was about climbing.
Just climb.
Was that it?
Was that the after credit?
Bro, are those fucking limping?
What the fuck do I do?
What do I do?
Like, we don't have a horse doctor here.
I don't even know what the fuck my girlfriend can do.
Is this just being dramatic?
Is that the fact that he like swam all the way back here?
Wait, am I alive?
I'm a fucking baby?
Bro.
Still... Oh my god.
What?
My girlfriend's gonna be my mom now?
Oh wait, is this... Oh, that's like Ico.
He's like the spiritual success... like the prequel to Ico.
Because he has horns too.
Bro, my girlfriend's my mom.
I knew... guys, I fucking knew grabbing anything was worth this.
I fucking knew it.
You guys are like, Doki, why didn't you grab anything?
I fucking knew there was no way.
Low point.
I saved up some time.
Everyone, I saw in my chat.
They were like, wow, this entire game was grabbing and she doesn't even grab at the end.
Because I knew it was useless.
There was no fucking point.
But what about the drama?
I should have been like, we.
What about the drama?
He jumped into the pool.
Wait, but the bridge is gone.
How the fuck is she gonna get home?
This is so sad.
Like seeing Arlo limping.
Oh my god.
Bro, how the fuck do we fix his leg?
This is home now.
Yeah, I'm like how is she gonna... the bridge is gone.
Where are we gonna get diapers?
Food.
Kill it.
The deer.
Why is this snow white shit?
She's so close!
Kill it for food!
Oh my god, this is great.
Because like the herbivores have never seen an actual carnival before.
So it's like the dodo bird.
It's like a dodo bird.
Where like dodo birds never encountered any like actual...
Actual like threat.
So like it was so easy to kill all the dodo birds.
Because the dodo birds just didn't know what is considered a carnivore.
And what is considered like a predator.
So the deers, they don't know.
They don't know.
So we'll just wait for it to walk up to us.
And then like snap its neck and then that's food.
Because it's never eaten.
I've never seen a predator before.
Eagles don't eat deers!
Okay maybe like baby deers.
I've seen an eagle pick up a fucking baby deer before.
Like not in real life but a YouTube video.
It's not ruining the...
What moment?
It was a fucking deer.
You know you've seen a video?
Of like a fucking eagle pick...
I think it was like an eagle picking up a fucking baby deer.
It's just like...
There's like a thing.
So a lot of parents are like super paranoid.
Because like there's been cases.
Where like eagles will try to pick up children.
Like they will try to abduct kids.
Because it sees it as like a fucking baby animal.
Yay!
Yeah eagles can pick up goats.
Now there's a fear in there.
Hahaha!
Yay we did it!
Now you have an additional fear.
If you become future parents.
And then like now you're like.
What if an eagle picks up my child?
My child will never go outside anymore.
New fear.
Yay!
We fucking did it guys!
Oh my god!
We fucking did it!
We beat Shadow Colossus!
And press X real fast.
Enter attack mode.
Press in front of the cross.
A statue?
What the fuck?
Did I just beat the game?
Oh new game plus a mirror world.
What the fuck is mirror world?
Anyway beat the game!
We did it!
Another game completed!
I'm gonna turn off the game.
I'm gonna turn off my playstation real quick.
I'm gonna turn it off.
Oh my god!
Oh yeah!
As promised!
I was gonna show you guys the new sub badges.
Let me uh...
I need to grab the uh...
Uhhhh...
Let me grab like...
The files real quick.
Oh my god I need to find it again.
Did I put as...
Oh...
New sub badges.
I'll show you guys.
It's so cute.
Oh my god.
I even have the...
My friend even gave me like alternatives.
Like alternatives...
Uh... ones too.
Alright let's see it.
Sub badges.
There we go.
Let me show you guys.
It's so cute.
Oh it's so fucking cute.
Woo!
Okay.
Downloads.
I put it in my downloads again.
Alright sub badge.
Here you go guys.
Look at this.
Look at this guys!
Look!
So tiny.
It's so cute!
Look at the little!
Look I...
They gave me alternatives with like...
The little handkerchief or like the non-handkerchief.
But I went with the non-handkerchief because like...
I felt like you know...
Um...
I wanted it to look dissimilar.
But oh my god and then there's me.
There's me over here.
Um... I sort of like baited...
My friend.
Because like... uh...
Even though like...
I commissioned them to draw...
Me.
We're gonna get a new...
Skin suit so that this one's gonna change...
In the future.
Like...
We're not even gonna hit that sub badge.
It's just there for decoration.
I just wanted to fill it all... all the slots up.
But like we're never even gonna get this...
Sub badge.
Like the last one.
Yeah.
The last sub badge is gonna change.
And I was just like...
This is... Fuck it.
I just wanted...
It's just a placeholder.
It's gonna... It's a placeholder.
So the new skin suit will have like...
It would be different from this.
JP!
Welcome to the Tomato Farm!
Welcome welcome!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you from 4 years in the future.
Hell yeah.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you thank you.
Can I ask for a birthday greeting to Scarlet Ghost?
She's a huge fan of you, Doki.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you thank you.
Of course.
Guys!
Happy birthday Scarlett!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Scarlett!
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Also another update.
If you guys don't follow me on Twitter...
So you know how like GamerSubs and I are hosting an art contest?
GamerSubs got back to me and they are sponsoring, funding the whole $8000 for the prize pool.
So like originally it was $7000 but then we decided to add...
I wanted to add an extra $1,000 and choose like 10 more winners.
Because there's been... we've recently... like I checked...
We've had 120 entries so far after one week.
And there's still like 3 to 4 more weeks left of the... 3 to 4 more weeks left of the contest.
So I was like, oh I want to... like I was like, oh my god.
And there's just so many!
There's so many!
They're all like really amazing.
They're all like so pretty and everything.
So that's why like I asked if I could add one more... 1k more to the prize pool.
So I can like pay more artists for all their amazing entries.
Because it's gonna be so hard to choose, Matt.
It's gonna be so hard to choose.
And then GamerSubs after they're like, yeah.
They're like, you know what Dokie?
We're gonna sponsor all the entire prize pool.
Like all $8000 of it.
Because at first it was they sponsored 5k.
I sponsored 2k to the 3k.
And then later on today...
They told me that they...
They're gonna sponsor like full fund the entire $8000.
So huge shout out to GamerSubs for the big support there.
For willing to like sponsor $8000 for artists.
It's actually crazy.
So crazy.
But yes!
Thank you all for joining!
I'm gonna fucking peace out now.
I'm super tired.
I'm very tired now.
We streamed for 4 plus hours.
So I'm gonna peace out now guys.
Hope you guys had a great time watching.
As always everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!